bien monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues donc nous recevons aujourd'hui
pour sa première audition devant une
autre commission le ministre des armées
et je vous souhaite monsieur le ministre
en notre nom à tous la bienvenue bien
sûr et je formule les voeux de réussite
dans cette nouvelle mission importante
en vérité
vous souhaiter la bienvenue dans cette
maison est un petit peu exagéré puisque
cette maison est déjà la vôtre je
rappelle que vous avez été élu sénateur
de l'eure et que ce département du reste
est bien illustré aussi par la présence
de notre collègue nicole duranton ce
mini-jeu forme également le voeu que
nous puissions à travers cette première
audition
initié une relation de confiance sur les
grands enjeux de la défense et de la
souveraineté de notre pays la résilience
de notre nation dépend aussi de notre
capacité à dégager des consensus
républicain sur les enjeux de défense
comme le montre la défense héroïque dont
fait preuve le peuple crânien la
résilience d'une démocratie passe par la
cohésion de l'ensemble des corps
constitués de la nation et aussi par un
fonctionnement robuste des institutions
dans lequel le parlement doit avoir
toute sa place
monsieur le ministre vous pourrez
compter sur le soutien plein et entier
du sénat et de notre commission à nos
forces armées et en notre nom à tous est
devant vous je souhaite une fois de plus
salué l'engagement des femmes et des
hommes de ses forces armées et rendre
hommage à celles et ceux qui en ont payé
le prix de leur vie ou dans leur chair
soyez assurés que nous sommes bien sûr à
vos côtés pour donner à nos soldats nos
marins nos aviateurs personnes service
santé des armées l'ensemble des
personnels civils et militaires de votre
ministère les moyens d'accomplir les
missions que le pouvoir politique leur
confie vous le savez la loi de
programmation militaire 2019 2025 a été
votée en juin 2018 par une immense
majorité du sénateur
chaque année le sénat a constamment
renouvelée ce soutien par le vote du
budget annuel de la défense et je dois
donner acte aux gouvernements précédents
que globalement les engagements ont été
tenus il faut rappeler aussi que 2021
devait voir l'actualisation législative
de la programmation militaire comme le
prévoyait expressément son article 7
vous le savez il n'en a rien été malgré
notre demande solennelle de respecter la
lettre de la loi de programmation le
précédent gouvernement ne s'est résolue
que sous la pression a organisé un débat
qui n'a du reste en rien permis de
remplacer une discussion au fond sur la
base d'un texte législatif il y avait
néanmoins beaucoup de matière à débattre
de manière transparente démocratique
afin de mieux accorder les priorités
nouvelles nous avions identifié des
dépenses rendues nécessaires pour
compenser le surcoût des opex les
travaux de pérennisation du char leclerc
le réassort à neuf de la cession de
rafale d'occasion à la grèce ou encore
le financement du plan de soutien a hero
nautique tous ces ajustements étaient
légitimes et nous étions prêts à tout
entendent y compris à comprendre que
certains programmes dans d'autres
domaines plus est est ralentie
malheureusement donc les choses ne se
sont pas passées ainsi et nous restons
avec un déficit du parc de rafale dont
je rappelle que la cession de 12
appareils prévus pour la croatie ne fait
toujours pas l'objet de commandes de
remplacement et je pense aussi bien sûr
à certains retards pris dans le soutien
à nos services de santé des armées dans
la rénovation des véhicules blindés
légers ou encore la préparation de ce
service très important à la haute
interdite
ces stratégies de mon point de vue et du
point de vue de nombre de nos collègues
aura été doublement
contre-productif puisque le non respect
d'une loi d'engagement de loi de
programmation a peut-être non pas zappé
mais en tous les cas porter atteinte à
la confiance que notre gouvernement que
notre commission pouvait avoir dans le
gouvernement vous avez annoncé devant
nos collègues à l'assemblée nationale
que le gouvernement respecterait la
nouvelle marge la nouvelle marge de 3
milliards d'euros pour le budget de 2023
c'est une attente forte et nous en
acceptons en l'auguré mais nous espérons
surtout que vous serez en mesure de
conserver cette ambition dans la durée
nos sujets de préoccupation concernant
la préparation nos forces plus
particulièrement le niveau des stocks de
munitions tuent longuement
personnellement l'occasion avec nombre
de nos collègues de souligner ce point
tout ceci a donné lieu à un même constat
que nos collègues députés thériault et
madame miralles qui est maintenant votre
ministre délégué ces questionnements
sont la simple illustration de notre
volonté de vous aider à aider nos forces
armées là encore je prends note de votre
volonté de reconfigurer ça a été votre
terme selon de nos stocks de munitions
enfin je souhaiterais que vous puissiez
nous éclairer sur le calendrier de ce
que le président de la république lors
de son discours à brienne a annoncé pour
ce qu'il a nommé je cite la réévaluation
de la loi de programmation militaire
d'ici la fin de l'année dans la
perspective de l'examen d'un texte début
j'ai évoqué le fait qu'en 2021 le
parlement n'y avait pas été associés est
ce que vous comptez monsieur le ministre
remédier pour la révélation demandée par
le président de la république remédier à
ce nécessaire effort de transparence
démocratique vis-à-vis du parlement
quelle sera par ailleurs le périmètre du
texte prévu pour 2023 est-ce que ça va
être une simple actualisation de la lpm
en cours ou une nouvelle lpm plus en
phase avec l'ambition 2030 mais aussi
avec les développements nouveaux du
contexte stratégique
quand vous le voyez monsieur le ministre
les défis qui vous attendent et qui nous
attendent ensemble sont nombreux
ray articulations du dic thiffault sahel
vous étiez au niger il ya quelques jours
et vous en dire un mot la poursuite de
notre engagement le vent le renforcement
de nos coopérations opérationnelles au
sein de l'union européenne la montée en
puissance au sein des forces de
réassurance de l'otan mais aussi bien
sur le développement du service national
universel dont l'impact budgétaire doit
être précisé sans qu'ils viennent
consommer les retraites de manière trop
élevé les ressources de nos armées vous
voyez que les sujets ne manquent pas et
nos collègues après votre prise de
parole vous interrogeront je l'imaginé
sur un certain nombre de ses sujets je
rappelle que cette audition fait l'objet
d'une captation vidéo et qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site du
sénat je vous propose donc de vous
exprimer devant la commission puis après
nous aurons un dialogue avec l'ensemble
de nos collègues féminines vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
je salue salue évidemment l'ensemble des
sénatrices et sénateurs que je suis
heureux de me retrouver ici je
reviendrai tout de suite sur la manière
dont j'imagine justement la qualité du
travail entre le parlement et peut-être
plus singulièrement le sénat encore avec
le gouvernement je me réjouis déjà
m'associer à vos pensées fraternelles et
républicaine pour les soldats tués
blessés et compris la ces derniers mois
à l'occasion de leur rendre hommage
collectivement avec le parlement
d'ailleurs lors d'une autre 14 juillet
évidemment de vous remercier pour vos
bons voeux de réussite auquel je suis
sensible de temps sur le terrain
républicain que sur le terrain si
permettre amical il est clair que la
situation nous oblige à repenser notre
travail avec le parlement tout
simplement parce que la manière dont on
va devoir définir un certain nombre
d'orientations stratégiques militaire
pour les années qui viennent vont être
commandés par l'urgence et je vais
revenir dans un instinct je commentais
commencé mon propos par aussi tout
simplement l'actualité opérationnel et
jeu politique d'un temps long dans
lequel on pouvait se déployer sur un
livre blanc prendre le temps de
réfléchir personne ne comprendrait michu
nos concitoyens ni chez nos partenaires
encore moins jeunes compétiteurs que
nous prenions un temps infini pour
trancher quelques réalités qui vont
s'imposer très très vite à nous et en
fait ces réalités seront avant tout
technique scientifique capacités
industrielles financières ou budgétaire
mais elles s'imposeront donc pour
répondre tout de suite à la première
question que vous nous avez posé
monsieur le président non seulement il
va falloir travailler assez vite et
c'est évidemment l'enjeu de ce dernier
semestre de l'année 2022 et je souhaite
sans mauvais jeu de mots le ferron
chambre avec eux les deux commissions et
donc peut-être quelque chose qu'on peut
construire partant du principe que les
nombreux rapports que la commission a pu
commettre tant d'ailleurs dans sa
composante défense que dans sa
composante affaires étrangères sont des
points d'appui évident plus le travail
qui existe au sein des armées plus le
travail qui existe évidemment dans toute
la matière que nous avons sur la place
de paris ailleurs qui de nous permettent
de procéder à une révision stratégique
rapide efficace sur lequel il faudra à
chaque fois pesé geindre et l' équilibre
entre le nécessaire rattrapage comme
d'ailleurs on l'avait appelé pour la loi
de programmation militaire actuelle que
nous connaissons les effets
d'application de retour d'expérience de
ce que nous connaissons au sahel mais
évidemment aussi en ukraine et ne pas
gâcher ou perdre de vue les nécessaires
innovation en prenant quelques risques
pour l'avenir comme en son temps
d'autres de nos anciens évidemment
général de gaulle évidemment l'état
cités ont pris des risques stratégiques
opérationnels et capacitaires la
dissuasion évidemment en état sur lequel
il faudra évidemment ceux projetés et
puis à titre plus personnel étant le
seul sénateur membre du gouvernement
j'ai donc un devoir moral et amicale les
avis du sénat est peut-être encore plus
de cette commission dont je fus
furtivement est virtuellement membre
pendant un mois avant que nicole durand
temps ne vous rejoignez que je salue
peut-être monsieur le président sans
être trop long ouvrir plusieurs tiroirs
dans lequel ensuite dans les changes que
nous pourrons avoir avec l'ensemble des
sénateurs ici présents pourront
peut-être appuyé mais mais je ne vais
donc pas déployer tout mais je vais
essayer de donner larchitecture au fond
de ce que je dois vous rendre compte
dans l'action du gouvernement devant le
parlement et aussi du plan de bataille
son environnement et encore or les
semaines et les mois qui viennent qui
peuvent donner le plan de charge et le
plan de travail
dès que je disais ce qui s'impose à nous
toutes et tous c'est évidemment le
contexte géopolitique est opérationnel
et sécuritaire c'est évidemment la
question de l'ukraine bon qui mobilise
l'essentiel des efforts diplomatiques et
opérationnel en tout cas sur le champ
sur 10 vers 100 depuis le mois de
février c'est la question évidemment de
la dalle ukraine sur lequel je le vois
bien je le sens bien il faut continuer
de refaire aussi la pédagogie devant nos
concitoyens de ce pourquoi ce qui se
passe en ukraine est très grave parce
que les principes de droits
internationaux et c'était
particulièrement prégnant dans les
échanges que j'ai pu avoir en afrique
sont des principes qui sont chers et
plus que indispensable à tout le monde
puisque le principe des souverainetés la
protection de la souveraineté ou la
protection des frontières en défendant
cette souveraineté de la protection des
frontières et ukrainienne ont défendu
par là même nos propres frontières pour
l'avenir et tous les pays du monde y
compris les plus fragiles ou les plus
faibles en général donc pour ses
richesses ce droit international dont je
reviens pas sur la nécessité de rappeler
les principes mais dans un but de
société dans lequel parfois des choses
sont très vite digérer et dans le fait
parfois où le repli sur soi même c'est
oublier qu'il ya quand même quelques
grands héritages et un patrimoine
important qu'est ce droit international
que nous avons en partage notamment
tirerons des conclusions terrible de
lendemains de la seconde guerre mondiale
que la france évidemment un rôle à jouer
particulier en la matière sa pause après
un certain nombre de sous question
évidemment l'aide française
sur le sujet ukrainien j'imagine qu'on y
reviendra c'est la question évidemment
du matériel qui sera lé talent non
létales on a beaucoup parlé des canons
caesar enfin d'autres évidemment sujets
sont sur la table je reviendrai
peut-être aussi sur la nécessité de re
compléter nos stocks au regard de ce que
nous avons pu donner à l'ukraine j'en
profite d'ailleurs pour rendre compte au
parlement de quelque chose que nous
n'avons pas encore rendu public mais fut
le président quand on sait que nous ne
venions d'acquitter la commande 18 canon
caesar auprès de nexter pour compléter
le stock de nos armées notamment pour ne
pas perdre sur le terrain de
l'entraînement évidemment notre
artillerie ne sert et fort heureusement
que pour l'entraînement je leur dis
aussi parce qu'on a pu lire des choses
un peu curieuse dans la presse comme si
on avait besoin de l'artillerie la
frontière allemande de nos jours forte
heureusement non je dis pour le sénateur
perrin et donc il est clair que ces
pièces d'artillerie en revanche aurait
pu entraîner en moins aurait pu
entraîner évidemment des défauts
d'entraînement pour nos forces armées
donc c'est pour ça que nous procédons à
l'art complétude ce qui va évidemment
nous permettre d'avancer dans le temps
il ya des enjeux évidemment dead et
d'accompagnement des ukrainiens en
matière de formation en matière de soins
des blessés nous aiderons dans la durée
mais je sais que nous reviendrons sur
ces questions dans un instant donc je
suis pas plus long il ya évidemment une
sous question dans l'aide à l'ukraine de
coordination européenne ou quoi
compenser quelles que soient nos
opinions politiques sur ce que doit être
l'union européenne dans cette commission
force est de constater qu'il ya un avant
et un après mois de février c'est
évidemment la question de la facilité
européenne de paix pour la première fois
on a quand même des mécanismes de
solidarité qui se sont déclenchés pour
faire de l'aide à l'armement défensif
pour l'ukraine s'est suffisamment
nouveau pour ne pas le leur dire avec
des coordinations de très pratique parce
que c'est pas le tout que d'aider
l'ukraine encore faut-il s'assurer qu'on
lui donne les choses dont elle a
vraiment besoin et qu'on s'assure de ne
pas le donner en double ou au contraire
d'avoir des manques importants donc
évidemment la coordination européenne
est appelée la question des sanctions
qui ne dépendent pas de mon ministère
enfin que je cite quand même pour
mémoire la question aussi d'accueil des
réfugiés notamment dans de différents
territoires qui ne dépend pas mon
ministère enfin je la réussite aussi
pour mémoire puisque nous avons pris
évidemment largement notre part et c'est
heureux et sans compter évidemment les
questions m la première école et
d'énergie le troisième sous sujet ainsi
l'actualité parlementaire entre ce matin
et demain c'est évidemment l'agenda
otaniens que la crise en ukraine art
déclenché je crois que pour le coup il a
une forme de résurrection de réveil si
on reprend les terminologies du présent
la république sur sur le temps avec une
hystérie elle vous savez qui s'est tenue
à madre à bruxelles puis derrière un
sommet de l'otan qui s'est tenu à madrid
là aussi je pense qu'on aura l'occasion
d'y revenir c'est la question de
l'élargissement suède et finlande c'est
la question est évidemment la posture
stratégique avec quand même des
sensibilités ou nuance entre alliés
qu'il conviendra quand même peut-être de
documenter devant vous dans un instant
dans les échanges notamment sur la
perception que l'on a de linteaux
pacifique peut être aussi rappeler
quelque chose c'est une évidence mais
que l'otan une alliance nucléaire et que
la france est une puissance dotée je le
dis ici au sénat ce sûrement plus
consensuel jeu les rappeler à la
commission de la défense de l'assemblée
nationale où ce sujet peuvent peut-être
prendre aussi une saveur ou un regard un
peu nouveau et faisons deux mois le
premier ministre défense en tout cas des
armées de la saga d'un public peut être
confronté à des formations politiques
qui désormais peuvent profondément
remettre en cause ce modèle de
dissuasion je pense que le sénat devra
regarder ça aussi avec beaucoup de pour
le bicamérisme devra aussi regarder cet
intrant politique nous vous me
semble-t-il parce qu'il n'ya pas de
dissuasion possible et efficace s'il
n'ya pas aussi un soutien de l'ensemble
de la population et ses représentants
dans l'est dans les chambres évidemment
fort et puis bien sûr il ya la part que
la france prend
dans la réassurance et la défense des
pays membres de l'otan et je le dis et
l'indiqué au président de cambon
qu'évidemment l'ensemble des membres de
la commission sont plus que les
bienvenus à se pencher sur ce qui est
fait est remarquable et remarqué en
roumanie dans lequel évidemment nous
avons projeté avec beaucoup de rapidité
des forces nous assumons le rôle de
nations cadres et on sait que c'est un
statut qui nous oblige y compris
d'ailleurs sur le terrain matériel et
budgétaire avec actuellement des travaux
importants sur le camp de de chick ou
d'une police du ciel y compris pour
l'estonie et la pologne nous sommes
passés à une défense du ciel faut bien
mesurer aussi la nature opérationnelle
de ce que l'armée de l'air ou de ce que
les moyens seule est redéployé peuvent
peuvent commander oui suscité en tout
cas suggéré et puis évidemment
le fait que prévu la république est
actée au sommet de l'otan que si besoin
malheureusement virgule en était d'être
capacité de nous élever un niveau de
type brigade en roumanie ce qui est
évidemment quelque chose
d'important je leur dis parce que pour
le coup les discussions que florence
parly pouvait avoir avec vous devant
vous il ya un an jour pour jour nous
n'avions pas l'interet d'ukrainiens
évidemment ce que nous faisons en
roumanie pas que constitue aussi un plan
de charge supplémentaire pour les armées
dont il conviendra aussi quand même d'en
refaire un point d'étape est compris sur
le plf pour l'année prochaine puisque
évidemment tout ça n'était pas forcément
prévu alors malheureusement si les
difficultés et les défis plutôt en
difficulté aussi s'accumulent sur la
frange orientale de l'europe moins que
l'on puisse dire je suis frappé de voir
et je les dis multiples reprises que ça
peut rendre une partie de paris ou de
l'opinion publique myope et de ne
regarder que le flanc est ce nous fait
oublier deux autres séries de terrain on
est on y reviendra dans le détail bon
c'est évidemment la question de la lutte
contre le terrorisme selon le principe
qu'on a le droit de plusieurs ennuis en
même temps l'ukraine ne balaie pas les
autres enjeux bon et d'ailleurs je le
dis aussi parce que notre résidence on
devra l'interrogé sur le terrain
sanitaires on a le droit d'avoir et du
terrorisme est une bande et me et une
guerre tout ça peut se cumuler en dix
ans en voici déjà des ingrédients de
méthodes de la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire
comment vous avez cité à juste titre
monsieur le président les services de
santé des armées voilà un service sur
lequel il va falloir forcément mobilisé
plus de moyens parce que sa résidence va
être extraordinaire vraiment
indispensable notre capacité à tenir bon
donc ça évidemment c'est un point dans
évidemment et la question du terrorisme
est donc évidemment il ya la question de
la situation au sahel et sur l'ensemble
de la bande sahélo saharienne est
d'ailleurs plus que la bande sahélo
saharienne
puisque tout ça se déplace c'est
évidemment une partie de l'afrique donc
il faut regarder avec lucidité la
situation sécuritaire moi je veux juste
dire d'un mot que je pense que quelles
que soient nos opinions politiques et
seront pas des opérations qui sont
menées et c'est bien naturel nous sommes
dans une démocratie ce qui d'ailleurs
est une force aussi dans notre manière
de déployer militairement dans les
différents pays du monde bon il faut
défendre les résultats de barkan je le
dis d'autant plus que m'avait invité
monsieur le président à prendre compte
de ce que j'ai entendu au niger et en
côte d'ivoire quand le prêt de ministres
indh et tout misé la défense du niger où
le président bazoum présent du niger
disent sans l'armée française sans la
france sans barkan les groupes
islamistes auraient fait tomber que tu
nous vous ferez pardonnez-moi la
capitale du mali il est clair que bamako
il est clair que quand ça vient des
autorités africaines
même s'assigne un bilan ça ne veut pas
dire que ça ne pose pas des questions
opérationnelles et stratégiques j'y
reviendrai pour l'avenir mais nos
soldats ne sont pas tombés pour rien je
pense qu'il faut le défend comme
d'ailleurs il faut défendre les
différentes coopérations une hygiène les
mines usma ou évidemment la force
takouba parce qu'elle était la signature
d'une première coopération européenne
évidemment très importante
évidemment il faut prendre acte
tout en n'étant pas d'accord
de la position des autorités du mali et
en rappelant que si le président
hollande a déclenché cette opération
serval puis évidemment
barkan au mali c'est que les autorités
souveraines du mali l'y avait invité et
l'avait demandé et que si nous sommes
amenés à mettre fin à cette opération
c'est parce que les autorités du même
pays même si sur de nouvelles autorités
dont on connaît la manière qui nous ont
accédé au pouvoir demandent la fin de
cette opération je redis ces évidences
parce que là aussi la campagne
présidentielle où une certaine presse
parfois plus car les 15 jurés les
opérations telles qu'elles étaient
menées orale s'inscrivent dans une
permanence à ses fortes que l'on peut
connaître sous la vème république
content du tout simplement à respecter
la souveraineté des autres pays et ça me
semble être évidemment et témoigne des
choses l'arête circuit paraître
accusations de deux de cette opération
entre le mali et niger et évidemment je
sais qu'on y reviendra une opération
logistique délicate avec des expositions
à de nombreux risques risques
terroristes toujours et puis comment ne
pas citer aussi évidemment l'émergence
du groupe wagner qui fait peser sur la
sécurité
de nos forces sur les intérêts de la
france une menace nouvelle d'ailleurs
moi je le dis aussi très franchement
nous ne sommes pas suffisamment
collectivement indigné de la mise en
scène macabre du groupe wagner sur la
base de gossip ou ce groupe a tenté
d'accuser la république française là
aussi quelles que soient nos
sensibilités politiques c'est la france
et l'armée française d'un crime de
guerre
évidemment l'armée française non
seulement n'a pas commis mais dans une
maison saine absolument épouvantable et
je le dis j'étais frappé de voir que ça
n'a pas suscité me semble-t-il
l'indignation de l'ensemble des élites
qu'elles que soient pas que politique
mais des élites de notre pays donc il
faut regarder aussi l'afrique avec de
lunettes nouvelles il y a en afrique des
champs de compétition qui sont
redoutablement complexe sur le terrain
terrorisme ça vous est connu mais
également aussi avec cet intrant nouveau
dans l'équation qui est évidemment le
groupe wagner mais je pourrais répondre
évidemment à vos questions sur ce sujet
il ya un jeune africain en matière de
sécurité a à construire mais peut-être
que j'aimerais entrer dans un instant et
ça me rend peut-être l'occasion de
rendre davantage compte les placements
en tant que tel récents en afrique ne
pas être myope c'est aussi de ne pas
oublier le reste du monde c'est
évidemment la question de la dope et
syfy qu en tant qu ancien ministre maire
événements et mettant particulièrement
mobilisées sur le dossier calédonien je
peux en témoigner enfin il est clair que
les défis qui se posent à nous aux
portes de l'europe sont à regarder aussi
avec l'ensemble des compétitions qu'on
peut connaître dans le pacifique nord et
qui ne sont pas sans
influence sur ce que nous pouvons
connaître dans le pacifique sud dont la
france est riveraine parce que nouvelle
calédonie parce que wallis et futuna
parce que évidemment polynésie française
sans oublier la relation aussi avec
l'inde ou l'indonésie qui est une
relation aussi désormais mature intime
en matière de défense et qui évidemment
fait peser aussi sur la france des
enjeux d'engagement sur lequel nous
sommes attendus et et de la question
docu sur lequel on reviendra aussi avec
eux évidemment la parole non tenue du
gouvernement morrison et la volonté du
nouveau gouvernement albanaise de
retraduire un axe entre paris et
canberra doit se regarder à travers
l'ensemble des enjeux stratégiques de
s'éteindre pacifique et donc ça posera
aussi la question monsieur le président
de la national des commissaires des
moyens que dans la prochaine lp m on
veut aussi donner à la vie militaire de
cette ado pacifique ça il faut pas se
payer de mots c'est forcément quelque
chose qui devra aussi peut être
permettre de trouver des moyens nouveaux
pour le faire mais avec un agenda aussi
qui ne doit pas être que évidemment
militaire il doit aussi même si on a
fait des choses le déploiement de rafale
en polynésie le fait qu'un sous marin
nucléaire d'attaqué ait pu faire une
longue patrouille dans le pacifique et
même en mer de chine est quelque chose
de plus que nous vous même d'assez
inédit que évidemment nous avons des
forces prépositionnées aux émirats
arabes unis on y reviendra aussi à
l'occasion de la visite d'état m b z ou
de djibouti m'enfin il est aussi un
agenda industriels aussi un agenda
culturel un agenda matière de diplomatie
climatique il faut penser 360 degrés
comme en afrique aussi on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir bon et puis une
fois que j'ai dit tout ça je sais
d'aller vite c'est évidemment de cette
ce constat
opérationnel géostratégique
sur lequel il faut se poser se reposer
pour essayer de définir quelle est notre
modèle d'armée demain et c'est seulement
comme ça qu'il faut le faire parce que
ils reviennent pire que de repartir du
modèle actuel ou de faire du capacitaire
point du capacitaire je le dis tout de
go hélas en aucun cas malheureusement on
pourrait passer historiquement à côté
justement de ce rendez vous qu'est la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
et même d'ailleurs l'exécution de la
marche à 3 milliards d'euros de l'hôtel
année prochaine alors
heureusement et merci monsieur le
président comment de vos propos sur
l'exécution de cette fois programmation
militaire j'ai bien entendu sur la
manière dont cette fois ceux ci le
parlement je pense vous avoir assuré
dans mon propos liminaire bon il est
clair qu'on a fait un choix c'est que
les crédits de paiement correspondent
aux autorisations d'engagement c'est
bien parce que c'est nouveau donc
et que de fait c'est nous savions et
florence parly il faut lui rendre
hommage savais que c'était là dessus
qu'elle serait jugée c'est bien légitime
parce que d'autres gouvernements avant
et c'est pas faire insulte querelles
politiciennes c'est factuel c'était
collectif et je me mets d'ailleurs
dedans même si j'étais ni ministre ni
parlementaire mais je pouvais en
proximité avec certaines majorité
il est clair que nous avions parfois
fait beaucoup dans le passé des fed
annonce qui ne crée pas d'effets
militaires réelles et pas des effets
militaires elle que pour nos industriels
effets militaires elle pour nos
compétiteurs et pour nos alliés et
d'ailleurs c'est un peu le le monde à
l'envers c'est que à l'otan désormais
puisque nous respectons nos crédits de
paiement par rapport à nos autorisations
d'engagement et par rapport à nos
objectifs au delà des 2 % du pipe parce
que dépensons du pullman avec la crise
covin malheureusement il ya des hauts
des bas non c'est surtout de manière
globale l'effort militaire réelle
recherché c'est sûr que c'est plus
facile de représenter la france un
mailing ministérielle de l'otan et alors
que nous remplissons nos propres
objectifs ça nous oblige collectivement
davantage bon et ça c'est vrai aussi
évidemment pour les partenariats
européens et donc la marche annuelle les
marches annuelles vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président ont été confirmées
et donc je vous confirme que nous vous
proposerons au parlement pour le plf de
l'année 2023 la marche 2 3 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires qu'est la marche
qui a été définie que vous avez arrêté
dans la loi de programmation militaire
et jeu j'en profite aussi pour dire qui
est évidemment ces efforts doivent se
traduire par une forme de tuilage pour
la loi de programmation militaire futur
je n'en dis pas plus parce que je ne
suis pas autorisé à en dire plus mais
que nous travaillons évidemment sur des
hypothèses qui sont pas sur des
hypothèses de régression du budget 10
ans en bon normand je veux dire par une
négation enfin les choses sont claires
l'enjeu désormais pour nous tous ces
deux c'est évidemment de nous assurer
que l'argent va au bon endroit et qu'il
produit des effets concrets alors ça se
voit quand même sur quand même un mot
sur les capacités parce que je les ai
cité sans les détailler on l'a vu avec
le 14 juillet d'un point de vue avec le
défilé j'entends d'impôt jeux populaires
nos concitoyens ont pu voir de manière
très concrète
l'arrivée dans un compte de nouveau
programme
scorpion pour l'armée de terre en étant
évidemment un des plus prodigieux un des
plus visibles d'autant plus que c'était
parfois l'armée de terre qui a pu faire
les frais ces dernières années de
certains choix budgétaires ne s'est pas
une critique sur l'arrêt roe la marine
évidemment mais les grands programmes
capacité à prouver parfois aspirait
énormément de crédits budgétaires et là
il est vrai que cette reprogrammation
militaire permet de nouveau de procéder
modernisation de l'armée de terre il
faudra continuer on connaît le griffon
on connaît les jaguars tout ça désormais
c'est l'art d'exécution c'est l'art de
produire et c'est l'art de remplacer
évidemment l'ensemble de ces deux c'est
de ces matériels
je cite aussi pour la marine l'admission
au service active du suffrin qui ouvre
l'ère de la nouvelle classe barracuda
c'est en sous marin nucléaire d'attaqué
c'est évidemment aussi un défi majeur
pour reprendre la marine nationale je
pourrais en citer d'autres en tout cas
c'était pour donner un peu du concret
alors on voit bien et j'accélère que
pour être trop long que il ya quand même
quelques réflexes évident que l'ukraine
nous donne après je serai heureux
d'entendre la commission de manière
peut-être formelle monsieur présent pour
concret justement cette co construction
ensemble entre les deux commissions des
deux chambres je pense capable d'une
grande revue stratégique pour voir que
sur les munitions il nous faut faire
mieux bas il faut le dire des choses et
appeler un chat un chat alors les
munitions c'est quoi c'est là où il faut
que évidemment on travaille moi j'ai
donné évidemment quelques instructions
et à la dgr et l'état major des armées
pour nous faire des propositions
concrètes pour dès 2023 être en
situation de faire un certain nombre de
réassort en munitions les munitions qui
sont là des missions de longue portée de
munitions individuel de munitions
d'artillerie donc les munitions comme on
le voit souvent dans la presse ça veut
tout dire et rien dire d'un missile
nucléaire après tout une munition on
voit bien que c'est pas de cela dont il
s'agit on est davantage sur les
munitions conventionnelles c'est un va
sans dire donc ça c'est évidemment
quelque chose sur lequel je devrais vous
revenir devant vous à l'automne mais je
le président pour vous dire au fond
comment on voit c est justement très
précisément pour l'année 2000 23 il est
clair que pour faire ces réajustements
il nous faut aussi avoir une industrie
qui est capable de délivrer et donc
c'est tout l'enjeu de ce que le
président de la république eurosatory et
à brienne a appelé autour de l'économie
de guerre alors certains aussi on dit
mais comment ça pourquoi économie de
guerre oui dès lors que d'un modèle
d'armée qui s'entraînent ou qui est
exposé à des missions type maintien de
la paix finul et c'est onusienne en
quelque sorte ou de la lutte contre le
terrorisme on avait un taux de
consommation de nos matériels ou non
équipement qui pesé pratiquement
toujours sur les mêmes gammes de
matériels pour faire très vite bon
désormais le réflexe ukraine montre bien
que si on devait aller vers une moyenne
haute intensité le niveau de
consommation serait plus rapide donc
c'est toujours la même chose c'est vieux
comme hérode mais il faut le rappeler
celle équilibre entre la massification
le nombre de matériels et le niveau de
technologie ou d'innovation de ce
matériel fort heureusement les choix qui
ont été faits sur la période de mai 18
2024 nous nous a fait quand même prendre
de l'avancé sur un certain nombre de
choses en matière d'innovation je
reviendrai sur des plans spécifiques
chars notamment aux sénateurs perrin je
cite une deuxième fois qu'ils m'ont
exclu sur les drones parce qu'on voit
bien que sur certains sujets il va quand
même falloir s'habituer pas trop
questionner sur les drones et sur un
certain nombre d'autres sujets cyber etc
il nous faut aller plus loin en tout cas
il est clair que
le dosage entre très grande innovation
et massification c'est à dire le nombre
de de nos de nos moyens alors l'appareil
un sous marin nucléaire n'est pas un
char qui n'est pas non plus alors un
armement individuel donc je vous fais
des propos généraliste mais il est clair
que c'est le noeud l'un des noeuds
gordiens de la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire sur lequel
évidemment il faudra que l'on que l'on
réponde alors je vais pas trop long une
fois de plus l'attention ça pose aussi
des questions sur les drones les 10 sur
l'espace sur le cyber ça pose la
question de l'hybridité ne reviendra sur
l'afrique notamment on y revient sur ce
qui se passe en ukraine
désormais nous avons beaucoup de moyens
civils qui sont détournés à des fins
militaires
ça aussi c'est un deuxième intrants
indispensable sans quoi on ratera la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
c'est que désormais il faut trouver des
réponses militaires à des sujets qui ne
prime abord ne sont pas militaires
qu'elle ait des informations
c'est la désinformation et ça dans
l'agenda de sécurité en afrique on veut
bien que la plupart des démocraties
africaines sont menacés d'attac qui
peuvent venir de très très loin et qui
passe davantage par un smartphone que
par des moyens classiques pour renverser
un gouvernement pour des choses très
directement donc ça évidemment c'est un
des points aussi claire et puis après
dernier point il ya une grande
coopération industrielle je les cite
évidemment mais c'est la question du
char du futur c'est la question du scaf
qui vont appeler aussi des choix
industriels importants avec évidemment
décalage industrielle en ce moment sur
lequel évidemment le gouvernement est
vigilant alors il n'ya pas d'armée 100
soldats y'a pas de soldats sans famille
ça d'un des points sur lequel je sais
que le sénat s'est beaucoup investi ces
dernières années et florence parly avec
ce plan famille a vraiment réalisé un
tournant dans la manière de faire vivre
socialement le ministère qui au fond
d'ailleurs permet de réfléchir sur c'est
quoi la militarité aujourd'hui et c'est
quoi un statut militaire dans les années
qui viennent ce n'est pas sans intérêt
sur les sujets qu'on a connus directive
temps de travail qui n'est pas sans
intérêt sur le sujet que l'on peut
connaître de nouveau la question des
pensions de retraite donc c'est parce
qu'on est au clair sur ce qu'est le
statut militaire qu'on peut être au
clair sur l'ensemble de ses juges et
j'avais pas l' inverse et c'est bien le
problème de ce qui a pu se passer ces
dernières années le dit vraiment avec
beaucoup d'humilité c'est que parfois on
a perdu juste que c'était au fond la
militarité dans notre société mais ça
c'est un des points sur lequel
évidemment il faudrait aussi que l'on me
dise des choses très fortes évidemment
la nation française la nation française
qui doit des choses assez militaire
l'armée française est une armée qui
combat général mais avec des pertes
je dis pas que c'est pas le cas toutes
les armées m'enfin c'est pas toujours
quelques désormais donc il est clair que
les françaises et les français la nation
doit quelque chose de particulier
évidemment à six militaires ça pose un
certain nombre de chantiers que je cite
pour mémoire évidemment la question de
la nouvelle rémunération le politique de
rémunération des militaires
avec des enjeux de pouvoir d'achat comme
pour tout à chacun en france la question
de la revalorisation du point d'indicé
par exemple et qui s'applique évidemment
aux armées et puis la question de la npr
m sur lequel j'ai eu l'occasion de
m'exprimer m'enfin je voulais évidemment
le témoigner devant vous le plan famille
je les dis c'est un des rares ministères
dans lequel il ya autant de mutations
35000 mutation par an avec des impacts
importants les impacts territoriaux
notre un certain nombre de sénateurs ici
sont des sénateurs élus de grands
terrains militaires d'avant territoire
militaire pardon donc ça pose aussi des
applications nouvelles je crains 50 de
proposition je serai heureux de
commencer par le sénat monsieur le
président pour le faire sur notamment le
rôle et la coordination entre les
collectivités territoriales et les
armées
être élu d'un département militaire avec
une base aérienne à evreux je suis
frappé de voir au fond que les armes et
parfois demande trop peu de choses que
les activités territoriales sur
l'affectation de logement dans le parc
des logements sociaux notre capacité à
traiter convenablement une manière un
peu différente les accueillants de
créach les a cognés l'école autant de
choses qui peuvent paraître simples pour
quiconque ayant été maires ou adjoints
au maire ici mais au final qui ne sont
pas suffisamment systématiser entre les
armées et les services des collectivités
locales le chèque nos collègues élus où
on vit en plus de faire ont envie d'en
être donc à nous aussi nous mettent à
leur portée et sans faire peser de
nouvelles charges aux collectivités au
contraire ce sont les armes et qu'ils
feront mais bien trouvé en revanche la
bonne grand-mère avec les locaux je
pense aussi qu'on doit pouvoir avancer
sur ce sujet il ya des enjeux
bâtimentaire important je reviendrai et
les enjeux de fidélisation et des enjeux
aussi autour des blessés sur lequel je
trouve que 50 de choses des familles de
blessé et les bce même des choses à mon
avis peuvent être faites dans les années
qui viennent de mots pour mes deux
secrétaires d'état vous avez eu la
gentillesse de sites témala miralles
évidemment à l'heure à s'exprimer devant
vous sur la question de la mémoire des
anciens combattants papa définir un
modèle d'armée pour demain si on ne sait
pas d'où on vient et donc la question de
l'identité de nos armées de son histoire
elle est créée je salue d'ailleurs un
ancien ministre ici présents qui a dû à
connaître sous le quinquennat de menus
du président hollande pardonnez-moi de
ses sujets et je pense que c'est notre
honneur justement en france que d'avoir
ce ministère sous secrétariat d'état en
charge des anciens combattants parce que
ça te dit quelque chose aussi de ce que
seront les anciens combattants demain
qui sont des anciens combattants de pex
qui sont les anciens combattants qui
servent actuellement en afrique que l'on
voit bien qu'on est à la croisée des
chemins comment prendre soin des grands
anciens jeu signant quand quelques
décisions pour des visages de la seconde
guerre mondiale et en même temps on voit
bien aussi qu'on a des jeunes quand 29
ou 30 ans qui ont déjà leur croix du
combattant et qui donc confrontés être
anciens combattants et tout ce que ça
veut dire donc là est un chantier qui me
semble tout à fait intéressant et pour
les grands départements militaire vous
en avez souvent beaucoup
parmi vos concitoyens parfois pas envie
d'ailleurs nous élus locaux donc
évidemment il faut il faut avancer puis
la question du service national
universel
qui existait déjà mais dont la double
tutelle désormais été actée par le
président de la république d'un point de
vue organique sur lequel je pense que je
la prendrai un certain nombre de vos
questions mais je le dis à le et ses nus
et il ya la question plus large et
globale vous permettrait de l'apprendre
plutôt comme ça de la résidence de la
nation s'il y avait un conflit je pense
que il faut
poser la réflexion sur la résidence
globale du pays en cas de conflit et
donc après se poser la question de
toutes les séries de réponse de la
responsabilité citoyenne dans cette
affaire et dont le et ses nus sans doute
enfin est un des éléments de réponses
mais qui doit se construire dans un tout
plus globale voilà me présenterai pas
été trop long mais je voulais brossé
l'ensemble des sujets qui permettent
ensuite évidemment d'approfondir ce
qu'il vous plaît d'approfondir merci
monsieur le ministre de
d'avoir évoqué les principaux sujets qui
retiennent bien évidemment l'attention
de la commission et singulièrement des
rapporteurs et avant de passer la parole
à mes collègues je retiens surtout votre
volonté réaffirmée de travailler en
étroite coopération avec le parlement du
meilleur général plus particulièrement
avec le sénat je pense que c'est une
bonne disposition ça a pu ici ou là
parfois nous manquait dans le passé et
je pense que ce sera un facteur de plus
grande efficacité sans plus attendre on
va commencer à lister question
alors au titre
on va prendre les rangs pour reprendre
les rapporteurs
cédric perrin pour le 146
merci monsieur le président monsieur
ministre merci pour ces propos
pour poutrer très juste et intéressant
monsieur le ministre je vous interrogez
d'abord sur les munitions si c'est un
sujet assez bateau en ce moment mais en
tout cas c'est un sujet sur lequel vient
d'intervenir un accord cadre qui a été
rendu public et qui mentionne la un
marché de 600 millions d'euros de
munitions l'appel d'offres date quand
même de juin 2021 c'est à dire bien un
an est-ce que vous pouvez nous apporter
des précisions au sujet de cet accord
cadre quels sont les munitions qui ont
été commandés y at il une accélération
des commandes pour tenir compte du
contexte actuel c'est à dire évidemment
de l'alimentation de l'ukraine en
munitions et de la reconstitution de nos
propres stocks ou est-ce que c'est
simplement la poursuite d'une démarche
déjà engagée avant la guerre en ukraine
et dans ce cas quelles sont les mesures
concrètes prises pour répondre à un
besoin en munitions que nous avions
identifiés depuis longtemps dans cette
commission et puisqu'on en parle depuis
une toque à moi j'ai souvenir depuis au
moins 2016 et qui est désormais
quantifier est unanimement reconnue même
si vos prédécesseurs nous expliquer que
nos alliés ayant des munitions l'urgence
n'était pas absolue je pense que ce
n'est pas une réponse qui était en tout
cas acceptable de notre point de vue
seuls aujourd'hui un socle de commandes
permanent permettra de consolider la
filière et de remonter rapidement en
puissance si c'est nécessaire et dans
cette perspective des munitions
cesseront tel dès cette année d'être la
variable d'ajustement au titre des
autres opérations d'armement souvent
victime de coupes budgétaires ou est-ce
que l'accélération et elle reportée à la
prochaine lp/m sous les drones vous
l'avez évoqué ma question en trois
volets en premier lieu à propos des
munitions row 2 ça a été une discussion
qu'on a eue souvent avec madame good
prédécesseur deux appels à projets ont
été lancés par la dg a hélas idée la
rina et pour neutraliser les véhicules
blindés à 50 km et colibri qui
neutralise ne t'avait cours pour
objectif de neutraliser un véhicule à 5
km ces appels d'offres sont tardifs
évidemment puisque je rappelle que dans
cette commission depuis 2010 est on
explique qu'il va falloir accélérer sur
ces sujets que nous sommes cinq ans
après seulement avec l'arrivée de ces
appels d'offres mais dont nous nous
félicitons ces appels d'offres sont
tardifs gelé bien de le dire on en parle
aujourd'hui aussi on parle aujourd'hui
aussi d'un approvisionnement possible en
drones américains de type sweetbay
switchblade pour combler rapidement nos
lacunes dans ce domaine
quelle est votre position sur ce sujet
ce que vous pouvez nous apporter des
précisions sur le calendrier les
quantités les spécifications la doctrine
d'emploi de ces drones et puis ensuite
je vous lève rapidement évoqué le sujet
des dames 12 dames pardon parce que le
système de drones aériens pour la marine
a du plomb dans l aile c'est le cas de
le dire puisque la marine a besoin de
faire vraisemblablement des choix
économiques
je ne jugerai pas de l'opportunité ou
non de se fournir de fournir ce matériel
nous amener à notre marine le seul
regret que j'ai c'est que on a pris
énormément de retard sur le sujet des
drones depuis 20-30 ans dans ce pays et
pour une fois qu on avait un matériel
qui arrive est quasiment à maturité
le fait de ne pas le choisir pour la
marine généra évidemment
l'abandon pur et simple de ce de ce
projet je trouve ça extrêmement dommage
je ressors ce qu'il en est exactement et
quelles sont les difficultés rencontrées
par ce programme et quelle est votre
position sur le sujet il ya d'autres
questions évidemment mais je vais
laisser du temps pour mes mes collègues
il ya un point sur lequel je vis à vis
d'un système semi liste quand on est en
haut quand on veut affirmer qu'on est
dans un état de guerre ça nécessite
aussi un certain nombre de mesures et
notamment des mesures qui nécessiteront
que nous diminuons les délais de
qualification notamment par un travail
très approfondi sur la problématique de
la norme parce que je ne suis pas
persuadé qu'aujourd'hui les normes qu'on
applique un certain nombre de matériels
soient tout à fait respecté dans des
pays où la guerre fait rage notamment en
ukraine voilà merci beaucoup
j'invite peut-être nos intervenants à
rester pour ce premier contact avec le
ministre sur des points les plus
généraux le cadrage parce qu'on aura
d'abord la discussion budgétaire
ou évidemment là on rentre un petit peu
dans le détail c'est aussi pour à la
fois laisser du temps à chacun alors
hélène conway est ce qu'elle est là
voilà alors allons-y
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez abordé la
reconstruction de nos stocks et
j'aimerais que vous précisiez comment
vous envisager la reconstruction de nos
capacités de systèmes césar après la
livraison de 18 unités soit presque un
quart de nos stocks à l'ukraine
le carnet de commandes de nexter
commence à être assez fournie notamment
grâce au succès remporté à l'étranger
les récentes commandes venant de
belgique et de lituanie par ailleurs le
marché de développement du système césar
marque 2 prévoit deux options a compté
2024 soit lancé la production de sons of
césar marque de 9 soit limitée cette
production à 33 unités neuves complété
par la rénovation du parc actuel donc
dans ce contexte la livraison ou les
livraisons à l'ukraine signifie tels que
18 unités 9 supplémentaires seront
commandés ou est-ce que le stock va être
complété à l'identique quel est le coût
de la reconstruction de ce stock est ce
qui nous intéresse pour le budget à
venir c'est
est-ce que ce budget sera pris sur l'
enveloppe de la lpm actuel ou sur la
prochaine et à quelle échéance cette
commande sera effectué et livre étant
donné que la production d'un canon
caesar comporte des délais
incompressibles incompressibles
d'environ 18 mois une question un tout
petit peu plus politique sur le dossier
particulièrement délicat du scaf savez
nous avons commis un rapport
parlementaire qui a été adopté par notre
commission notre commission a aussi
oeuvré au rapprochement des entreprises
dassault aviation et airbus mais
aujourd'hui les négociations patinent
bon je ne pense pas que nous ayons envie
de revenir sur le principe du meilleur
athlète niro négocier les grands
équilibres qui doivent permettre la
préservation des compétences critiques
notamment de l'entreprise dassault mais
on vient d'apprendre à l'occasion du
salon de farnborough que le japon
pourrait devenir partenaire du programme
tarp est concurrent du scaf avec les
britanniques
les italiens et les suédois
en 2020 dans ce rapport parlementaire
nous inquiétions d'un projet qui
aboutirait cinq ans c'est à dire le
nôtre après le projet big britannique
soit en 2040 avec les retards pris on
peut envisager peut-être aujourd'hui
2050 donc pourriez vous nous dire un
petit peu quels sont les résultats des
premiers contacts que vous avez et
peut-être vos orientations s'agissant de
la coopération franco allemande
y aura-t-il une différence avec le
quinquennat précédent merci merci hélène
alors ôté du 144 notre ami allizard
n'est pas là donc je pense que c'est
yannick vaugrenard qui va parler pour
les deux oui mais je vais faire très
très bref monsieur le président pour
merci pour les eaux tout le monde puisse
intervenir donc les questions de
financement et de réglementation
européenne nous allons nous l'évoquerons
avec pascal allizard l'occasion d'une
prochaine rencontre
donc du coup je vais me limiter
questionnement s'agissant du
renseignement six ministres
c'est un sujet délicat important et je
tiens avant de poser mes questions à
rendre hommage à l'ensemble de nos
services de renseignement pour le
travail qu'ils accomplissent la plupart
du temps dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles la programmation militaire
donc 2010 2025 a retenu du reste le
renseignement et le cyber combat dans
ses priorités de recrutement ce que nous
constatons à l'examen des lois de
financement chaque année mais plusieurs
sujets de préoccupations ont retenu
notre attention tant du côté de la dgse
en évoquant la sphère au cul ce que la
question concernant le moyen donnée au
renseignement
lorsqu'on a seulement constater de coup
d'état ou au mali ainsi que le
changement de directeur de la direction
du renseignement militaire ceci étant
intervenu pendant la guerre en ukraine
le 13 juillet donc tout récemment
monsieur le ministre vous avez publié un
arrêté portant organisation de la
direction générale de la sécurité
extérieure dgse pour ce qui peut en être
dit de manière publique
quels sont les objectifs de cette
réforme les améliorations qui sont
attendus pour ce service et sa
collaboration avec les autres entités du
renseignement militaire et de défense je
vous remercie
merci annie je vais au passage rendre
hommage de travail que fait pour notre
compte yannick vaugrenard qui nous
représente à la cnct r la commission
nationale de contrôle des techniques de
renseignement
une commission particulièrement
consommatrices de temps et le faire avec
beaucoup d'application
au titre du 178 de la préparation à
l'emploi des forces olivier cigolotti
puis michel gros
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre le président la république
annoncé il ya quelques semaines une
nouvelle loi de programmation militaire
et dès 2021 notre commission rende un
rapport sur l'actualisation lp/m liste
en série de deux points de vigilance à
surveiller
parmi ces points de vigilance était
pointé le service inter armes et des
munitions
la prochaine lpm ne pourra pas faire
l'économie de ces sujets sans parler
effectivement de redimensionnement du
service en charge de ces munitions et
puis deuxième question rapide avec mon
collègue gilbert roger quelques semaines
avant la pandémie nous avons produit un
rapport sur le porte avions de nouvelle
génération dont les préconisations ont
été largement reprises dans les études
amont vous n'avez pas évoquée dans votre
propos introductif pouvez-vous nous
apporter quelques assurances est ce que
le calendrier sera respecté et est ce
que les études à monde se poursuivent
conformément à ce qui était prévu je
vous remercie merci
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre a tant que coureur rapportrice
le programme cent soixante dix huit je
veille à la prise en compte des besoins
des services de soutien et je défends la
nécessité de l'as rome remontée de la
préparation opérationnelle pour le
service de santé des armées le déficit
est passé pour les médecins de premier
recours de 97 postes en 2020 à 136 en
2021 cette évolution est extrêmement
préoccupante ceci conduit à concentrer
sur les mêmes personnels la charge de
projection du service le taux de
projection des équipes médicales atteint
125 % malgré l'apport des réservistes il
ne cesse d'augmenter le taux de
projection des équipes chirurgicales
atteint même 200 % vous avez annoncé
dans votre introduction venir en aide
aux blessés à l'ukraine comment allez
vous vous y prendre dans ces conditions
quelles mesures d'urgence seront prévues
pour la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire pour le rsa mais aussi pour le
commissariat central et tous les
services de soutien de nos armées la
guerre en ukraine sur le sol européen
démontre l'importance de ses services
pour une armée même si je ne souhaite
pas que nous devions en faire un jour
l'expérience a démontré aussi
l'importance de la préparation
opérationnelle
nous ne pouvons pas attendre 2025 pour
atteindre des niveaux de préparation
conforme à nos engagements
internationaux
comme le prévoit l'actuelle loi de
programmation les taux de préparation ne
se décrète pas d'une année sur l'autre
la préparation opérationnelle
se construit dans le temps de
qualification en aguerrissement quelle
mesure prévoir dans ce domaine la
prochaine lp m les objectifs de
prouesses de progression seront petit
cette fois-ci communiqués au parlement
nous nous y attacheront merci
avant qu
avec le ministre répondra
rapporteur ou budgétaire donc jeunes
brièvement la parole à il avait vraiment
pas vers eux catherine dumas qui
rapporte la mission de la commission sur
la méditerranée mais n'anticipons pas
puisque le rapport à part encore été
présenté
monsieur le ministre je souhaite vous
interroger sur un sujet d'avenir dans
lequel votre prédécesseur à l'hôtel de
brienne s'était beaucoup investi en
effet depuis le 14 février dernier les
forces armées françaises se sont dotés
d'une stratégie ministérielle de
maîtrise des fonds marins ce document de
référence a mis notamment en lumière
l'importance stratégique des câbles sous
marins de télécommunications
concentré au large de nos côtes en
méditerranée et qui pourrait constituer
notre talon d'achille dans la mesure où
ils assurent 98% de nos liaisons de
données avec l'étranger le contexte
actuel dans lequel on observe une montée
inquiétante des tensions en méditerranée
orientale nous oblige à nous doter des
capacités nécessaires à assurer la
surveillance et la protection de ces
câbles y compris par des moyens
militaires
pourriez vous nous indiquer si le
tournant engagés dans ce domaine sera
maintenue dans le temps nous dira quelle
échéance vous espérez doter la marine
nationale des équipements nécessaires à
la surveillance et à la protection en
méditerranée de ses infrastructures
essentielles merci merci isabelle 4e
techno merci le président et le ministre
dans le cadre de cette mission sur le
réarmement en méditerranée je voudrais
aborder le sujet des conséquences de la
guerre en ukraine sur la stabilité de
notre voisinage et en particulier dans
les balkans occidentaux
plusieurs no 1 le cutter nous en fait
part du fait que la guerre actuelle
pouvait en effet avoir un effet
déstabilisateur sur cette région qui est
située aux confins de l'union européenne
donc quelle est la doctrine des armées
pour lutter contre la guerre
informationnelle que la russie mène dans
les balkans notamment en serbie où elle
essaye d'imposer un récit qui est non
seulement contraire à nos intérêts
mettez qui est également mon songer au
regard de la réalité sur le terrain et
enfin vous avez parlé du matériel de la
massification de l'innovation en ce qui
concerne les instruments en ce qui
concerne les armes qui sont livré à
l'ukraine aujourd'hui quels instruments
de contrôle avons nous pour nous assurer
qu'elles ne seront pas diffusés dans
d'autres pays d'europe orientale et
notamment dans les balkans avec bien sûr
le risque d'alimenter des conflits
futurs dans cette région merci voilà
monsieur oui je vous donne la parole
pour répondre à porter mais peut-être
sans trop anticiper sur le budget pas
savoir je suis pas certain que tous les
choix et été arrêté et ça permettra à la
douzaine de
s'exprimer à la suite merci monsieur
président noir il est vrai que
l'exercice à la fois empreinte a déjà la
discussion budgétaire et puis évidemment
aussi à la construction de la prochaine
doit pourvoir masoni terme dans le temps
c'est utile parce que ça fixe bien les
points d'intention de la commission
domaine oui ça ça donne en tout cas des
éléments je prend peut-être par l'ordre
décroissant
et je parle pour le coup je suis quand
même néophytes dans cette commission
j'imagine qu'à des formats sans
retransmission qui permettront peut-être
de traiter des sujets plus confidentiels
lorsque vous ne demanderez nous
garderons pour la fin de la séance la
possibilité de couper la captation et de
répondre plus loin particulièrement mais
c'est à votre demande car d'une manière
générale les sénateurs souhaitent que
les les séances soient dûment identifiés
parce que sans ça elle ne leur sont pas
comptabilisés comme étant présents
oui
c'est une précision utile dans le moment
venu je serai à me rappeler monsieur
l'heure
nous même inspecté par tout un tas de
sites qui ne souhaite que notre bonheur
et donc s'il n'y a pas de procès verbal
s'il n'y a pas de compte rendu et si on
n'est pas identifié on est très bien
comme absents dont il est clair que moi
j'ai à coeur de rendre compte au
parlement le plus précisément possible
mais que la notion de plus précisément
possible peut-être est incompatible avec
eux la présence la présence de deux
téléphones portables ou de houe
évidemment de retransmission tout ça
monsieur présent si vous êtes d'accord
en fonction des thèmes ont réussi et moi
je me plierai évidemment un soin que
vous souhaitez vous décidez
balkans occidentaux ça a été un des gros
points et des grandes et des grandes
rencontres européennes on l'a tous suivi
évidemment de ces derniers temps mais
aussi de l'otan et ça c'était quand même
un point assez nouveau puisque pendant
le sommet de madrid un dîner tout entier
était consacrée à une rencontre
complètement dédié à la question des
balkans occidentaux
ce n'est pas sans recoupé des agendas
onusien puisqu'un certain nombre de nos
partenaires et nous même historiquement
sont présents évidemment aussi dans la
kfor ça pose aussi bien sur des
questions de suivi des demandes un
certain nombre de pays la bosnie
évidemment aussi de l'autre côté les
serbes de l'autre côté nos amis croate
donc mais qu il ya un agenda balkans
dont il est clair que la
l'invasion de l'ukraine par la russie a
créé une focale et un agenda très précis
sur suède finlande pour les raisons que
l'on connaît a ouvert de manière très
intense la question de l'adhésion de
l'ukraine et l'union européenne on y
revient pas mais qu'on serait incomplet
s'il n'y avait pas effectivement c'est
un agenda dédié aux aux balkans
occidentaux sur lequel un certain nombre
de réassurance auront été donné donc
vous avez raison de le rappeler sur le
suivi des armes
donné à l'ukraine nous prenons
évidemment d'infinies précautions
dans les limites de ce qu'un champ de
bataille permet évidemment de connaître
et de savoir est un principe c'est quand
même la confiance avec les ukrainiens et
que globalement si eux mêmes peuvent
connaître des difficultés sur du
matériel ils nous le disent et qu'au
moment où je vous parle nous n'avons pas
identifié de problème complètement
direct après cela se repose beaucoup
évidemment sur la relation de
partenariat de confiance que nous avons
entre armée et compris entre ministres
avec un niveau de coopération mais enfin
un peu plus la situation étant
suffisamment difficile sur le terrain il
est clair que tout ça est parfois très
très difficiles ont compliqué sur les
câbles c'est un enjeu majeur vous avez
cité la méditerranée faut pas oublier
nos territoires d'outre-mer qui sont
traversés évidemment par des
infrastructures numériques d'un gabarit
très très important j'ai fait de voir
les grands projets qui peuvent traverser
demain la polynésie française et nos
zones économiques exclusives et donc ça
c'est un d un des gros morceaux de la
prochaine loi de programmation militaire
donc votre quelque chose de préciser ce
que je confirme le tournant la réponse
est oui est-ce qu'on va continuer de
donner des moyens financiers à la marine
nationale la réponse est oui et
d'ailleurs ils ont déjà parce que la
nouvelle vous avez forcément vu ça mais
la nouvelle gamme de nos fremm
évidemment permettent déjà d'avoir des
instruments de surveillance de ce point
de vue tout ne se fera pas qu'avec les
armes et c'est là aussi il faut qu'on
ait des partenariats efficaces avec un
certain nombre aussi de d'acteurs
pourrait revenir dans un autre cadre
typiquement que celui que nous
connaissons ici dame maintenant mais il
est clair que c'est que c'est clair non
identifiés sur le service de santé des
armées moi je les dis en propos
introductif pour moi c'est un service
sur lequel il faut investir de manière
majeure d'autant plus que j'ai une dette
vis-à-vis de ce service en tant
qu'ancien ministre et outre-mer ou sans
le service de santé des armées une part
importante de nos capacités sanitaires
en outre mer ce serait malheureusement
effondré mais ce n'a pas été
suffisamment dit est saluée y compris
dans des territoires de la république
dans lequel l'état n'était plus
compétents sur le terrain sanitaire la
polynésie la nouvelle calédonie dont
vous savez que ce sont des pays
d'autonomie et que la compétence
sanitaire a été transféré au collectif
l'idée sur generis et il est clair que
sans le sssa
les choses auraient été autrement plus
violentes c'est ce que je disais en
introduction on a le droit d'avoir
plusieurs ennuis en même temps on a
droit d'avoir une guerres et une
pandémie en même temps et c'est ça en
fait une des conclusions tout simple
évidence qu'il faut avoir ça pose la
question aussi du rapport de la relation
que le sssa peu à voir avec la médecine
de ville ou l'hôpital public civil
je crois que c'est un point important et
ça posera clairement la question madame
la sénatrice de la stratégie des
réserves au sein du sssa
g10 la question se posait pas le service
militaire faisait comme un médecin
interne se voyait confier des galons de
médecin capitaine au médecin commandant
certains spécialistes directement
médecin lieutenant colonel médecin chef
de deuxième classe pardonnez moi
et que le médecin vivait toutes ces vies
avec son son engagement à servir dans la
réserve soit il le levée soit ne levait
pas s'il était convoqué ce n'était pas
convoqué il est clair que la suspension
du service national a eu cet effet
d'avoir un et c'est ça qui s'est
beaucoup professionnalisé ça c'est la
bonne nouvelle mais qui en même temps
c'est aussi beaucoup peu recentrer sur
un certain nombre de missions et on voit
bien que les nouvelles crises sanitaires
le réemploi de manière très dense
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup d'unités qui
sont fatigués vraiment parce que celui
cité par les opérations sollicité par la
crise que vivent les dix et on ne pourra
pas continuer indéfiniment comme ça je
me dis comme je le pense et c'est un
service sur lequel je sais qu'on met
beaucoup de moyens n'est pas d'armé qui
peut se projeter si elle n'a pas
l'assurance que ça suivra son terrain
sanitaire ya pas de famille qu'il
laissera partir
ces soldats s'ils n'ont pas l'assurance
que tout est mis en oeuvre ou en cas de
pépin on soit capable de tout donner
pour accompagner le blesser ou le cas
échéant aussi un syndrome d'autres
pathologies je fais aussi ainsi sur le
sssa je pense aussi qu'il faut remettre
des moyens sur d'autres spécialités
on le voit bien la psychiatrie et les
syndromes post traumatiques
les blessures psychiques sont tout aussi
violente que certaines blessures
physiques chez le combattant ou chez le
blesser or la question de la psychiatrie
dans notre pays est un sujet vaste me
semble-t-il qui dépasse les seules armes
et vous il est clair que ce sont des
spécialités sur lequel en plus on peut
avoir de la dignité en matière de
recherche et que les armées américaines
israéliennes alors services de santé
respectifs ont fait des choses et sur
lequel on n'a pas à rougir de l'embryon
de ce qui existe
on doit pouvoir faire mieux en nombre de
médecins en passant par les réserves
mais aussi sur le terrain de l'as de la
recherche sont des éléments très
pratique très concret moi j'ai demandé
au médecin général qui est
directeur du service sont désormais de
nous faire des propositions et d'essayer
de il y avait cette stratégie sssa 2030
je crois que le vide nous doivent faire
accélérer les choses et que mon avis
faut resserrer le calendrier sur
certains aspects le détendre sur
d'autres parce que c'est bien d'avoir de
la vence en matière d'innovation mais je
pense que c'est absolument clé vous avez
parlé du service des munitions gera joue
très bien volontiers le service des
essences ou les différents commissariats
vos sites les unités dont on parle peu
on a vu 14 juillet défilé les greffiers
des armées c'était une nouveauté je
pense aussi que c'est bien que le
ministre comme la commission la
commission comme le ministre s'intéresse
aussi à tous et tous ces services qui
sont pas forcément très connu mais sur
lequel l'armée de soissons
s'effondrerait s'il n'y avait pas ces
services de soutien principe de nous
soutenir c'est qu'il ya plus et plus de
soutien c'est qu'on s'effondre donc le
nécessaire voilà je voulais faire une
assise plus longue même à centris mais
je suis complètement militants je
rajoute que tout ce qui a été fait sur
le ségur à des effets au conventionnel
et c'est une bonne chose sûre de sa vie
décente et les armes évidemment n'a pas
oublié les soignants militaire ça va
sans dire je pense aussi qu'ils les
enjeux sur leur carrière sur les
passerelles bref je pense qu'il faut
voilà si le le sénat aussi certains
sénateurs souhaitent être associés
particulièrement réflexion sur le
laisser sa vie dans le très ravi de le
de le faire renseignements autre secteur
sur lequel il a des progrès tout à fait
significatif
ces dernières années
juste que le sénat s'est interrogé je le
comprends j'ai le dessinateur j'aurais
fait pareil sur l'actualité malienne sur
rochus en se disant mais au fond est ce
que montrent les moyens qui sont mis sur
la table et ce qui est vraiment possible
de faire où est la vérité c'est normal
que le représentant bien sûr et c'est
normal que l'homme le parlement pose la
question est d'ailleurs je suis heureuse
le directeur général secteur extérieur
dans un format idoine et haddock devant
vous a pu apporter un certain nombre de
réponses ça donne aussi mon avis là un
peu le chemin de la qualité que l'on
doit trouver de relations entre le
parlement et l'exécutif bon il faut
mettre des moyens supplémentaires et on
va continuer normal puisque dans la
trajectoire la programmation militaire
vous avez toujours une part qui va au
service je rappelle la très connue des
gse là un peu moins connus direction du
renseignement militaire et là encore
moins connue la direction la drs dé la
direction des renseignements la sécurité
de la défense qu'est le troisième
service de renseignement du ministère
qui n'est pas connu du grand public mais
qui est tout aussi important parce que
c'est le directeur qui ce succès la
direction pendant qu'ils s'assurent de
l'intégrité la sûreté de nos armées
espionnage ingérence
radicalisation
là où il ya des hommes et de l'hommerie
donc par définition il ya aussi un
service qui l'ancien dpsd s'assure de
cette intégrité donc le trajectoire sur
les moyens elle elle s'applique
évidemment aussi sur sept français à vis
là pourquoi
parce que le métier évolue et que
évidemment les besoins technologiques
sont gourmands sur le terrain budgétaire
la dgca 20 ou 30 ans
de toutes les évidences pas la même
direction technique sur les terrains
numérique donc ça ce sont des moyens
mais derrière ce sont des moyens
d'infrabel se sont aussi évidemment des
moyens de ressources
d'avoir des combattants cyber avoir des
gens qui sont capables d'interagir sur
ces sujets bah évidemment ce sont des
jaillir des jeunes ce sont des jeunes
gens a pas que qu'il faut détecter
formés mais aussi mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs fidéliser dans un milieu dans
lequel lorsqu'on a commencé très bon on
peut très vite être recruté par un gaza
ou part évidemment grandes entreprises
du secteur même quand on a très envie de
servir son pays
i évidemment ce qui est proposé à la fin
du mois est nettement supérieur à ce que
l'administration de la défense peut
proposer bon donc ça c'est aussi un des
enjeux de réflexion sociale pour
l'avenir ça de fidélisation
nombre de métiers au travers des
services de renseignement je vous
reviens pas sur ce qui a été dit sur
rochus et sur le mali la réalité aussi
il faut le redire y compris notre à nos
concitoyens le renseignement non pas une
science exacte et que les états unis
d'amérique met beaucoup de moyens dans
les services de renseignements je crois
aussi qu'ils ont connu quelques
déconvenues donc il ya aussi des
réalités avec des aléas comme
malheureusement l'art de la guerre
suggère aussi d aller en vie dans des
sociétés de qui tolèrent de moins en
moins là l'air enfin c'est aussi notre
devoir collectif que dans la plaie tout
ça évidemment on n'est pas n'est pas
toujours si évident que cela la réforme
de la dgse j'ai effectivement signé les
arrêtés il ya maintenant quelques jours
ils ont été publiés au journal officiel
son travail important que d'un arrêt me
accord général a mené avec un certain
nombre de cadres interne à l'âme et la
boîte comme on dit c'est une
réorganisation qui était voulue et
souhaitée par le service partant du
principe que son organisation n'avait
pas beaucoup évolué ces dernières années
pape a demandé aux services de regarder
vers l'inde au pacifique de s'intéresser
évidemment aux menaces plus
conventionnel et de rouvrir le jeu s'en
tirait des conclusions
d'organisation le métier des packs
africain il n'est pas que prolifération
il est désormais les risques étant
multiples le service s'adapte évidemment
à tous à tous les risques donc c'est pas
un grand soir loin s'en faut c'est une
manière d'organiser les savoirs et
surtout de décloisonner une partie de la
direction générale
au fond si je le veux le dire en deux
mots étant présent sur ce sujet
d'une organisation par métier le
technique les opérations papam
l'administratif le soutien on va essayer
de passer à une direction par zone
géographique c'est aussi si je devais
résumer en deux phrases il s'agit de
cela et en cela c'est pas la grande
révolution parce que beaucoup d'autres
services de pays amis le même gabarit
ont déjà procédé à ce genre de juste
donc c'est ce que nous faisons le cas
échéant dans un format plus discrète je
pourrais évidemment répondre aux siens
comme de vos questions sur ce sujet
alors la famille des munitions jeu
peut-être le faire en plusieurs morceaux
puisque vous êtes évidemment nombreux à
y être revenu même la ministre conway
mouret monsieur perrin et et monsieur
sigheti sur eux s'ils ne le dit pas non
sur d'abord vous êtes le porte avions de
nouvelle génération j'en ai pas parlé
parce que j'ai oublié
donc présente mes excuses évidemment ça
fait partie de l'ensemble des grandes
stratégies qu'on est en train de
déployer mais que vous aurez raison en
tant que sénateur de venir percuter de
vos questions lorsqu'on arrivera sur la
nouvelle génération de npm tels que oui
on continue de préparer les choix enfin
il sera bien logique quand même
carrément donné on se pose
collectivement la question et ça fait
des échos a d'ailleurs aux questions du
sénateur perrin sur les drones enfin
j'veux dire à quoi ressemblait le naval
de cent trente ou quarante ans c'est pas
une question médiocre
le niveau là de discussion bon à quoi
ressemblera notre système d'aviation de
chasse dans trente ou quarante ans qu'au
fond la question des drones ont miroir
c'est aussi quand même se poser la
question à quoi ça ressemble bah c'est
pas médiocre puis sachant qu'on a aussi
quand même déjà des intrants qui
permettent de faire un certain nombre de
réponses que certains pays qui n'ont pas
vraiment d'aviation de chasse se disent
on peut faire tout drôle parce que j'ai
lu dans la presse qu'il faudrait faire
pareil ben c'est juste méconnaître le
fait que nous avons une des composantes
de la dissuasion qui a est reporté déjà
par définition on voit bien que nous on
aura toujours une une aviation de chasse
quand on procède comme ça par
raisonnement et par rationalité en
quelque sorte ça me permet déjà de
donner un certain nombre de visages ou
wii sur le groupe et on a un groupe
aéronaval du futur évidemment qu on y
travaille d'autant plus que la nouvelle
place du barracuda avec le suffrin déjà
est un morceau de ce que pourrait être
un groupe aéronaval de demain après faut
se poser des questions de calendrier
faut se poser des questions de benchmark
faut regarder aussi un peu ce que font
nos alliés parce que le système porte
avions par définition il a beaucoup de
sens aussi quand il s'inscrit dans un
tout alors que d'autres équipements au
contraire sur le de totale souveraineté
personnelle intime individuel le on perd
on avale aussi longtemps mais je veux
dire parfois ça aussi un sujet où est-ce
qu'on veut aussi intervenir demain d'un
parlement puisque c'est aussi la
commission des affaires étrangères doit
aussi donner à mon avis des directions
est compris dans de son contrôle à
l'exécutif
indo pacifique
jusqu'où va-t-on que prévoit ton c'est
un peu ce que je disais tout à l'heure
je ne veux pas faire dès cet après-midi
la réflexion stratégique sur la lpm
enfin le coeur est là à coup sûr le
locker le coeur est ici ça change je le
rappelle parce que notre opinion
publique finit par oublier qu'en plus
nous avons des choix technologiques qui
nous sont parfois propres ou que nous
avons en partage avec les américains le
fait d'avoir de la propulsion nucléaire
sur nos porte avions et les etats-unis
la france
qui donc pose des questions évidemment
d'autonomie capacité à aller très loin
donc c'est aussi pour ça que des choix
de propulsion nucléaire avait été fait
donc tout ça évidemment il faut le leur
interrogé de manière de manière
complètement global alors si on n'y va
pas réagir sur les munitions
déjà avant de parler des munitions c'est
bien de parler de ce qui peut envoyer la
munition ça me permet de répondre à la
ministre sur évidemment le sujet d'une
des canons caesar donc
globalement c'est une enveloppe de 85
millions d'euros qui vont nous permettre
de faire s'être complétude
l'idée étant de recompléter comme je le
disais au point d'être introductif pour
ne pas abîmer les plans d'entraînement
et de formation de nos artilleurs ce
fort heureusement notre artillerie ne
sert pas enfin ne sommes pas engagés sur
un théâtre en dentelle on peut voir des
pièces d'artillerie prépositionné il ya
des vieilles pièces d'artillerie qui
sont à djibouti et c'est en tout cas
pour les canons caesar il est clair que
l'enjeu c'est de ne pas perdre en
compétences et de permettre à nos
artilleurs de ne pas passer trop de
temps sans des plans de formation
évident d'autant plus que nous avons été
contents d'avoir des soldats formés
parce que eux-mêmes ont été parfois
formateur pour d'autres si vous voyez ce
que je veux dire donc ça pour nous ses
clés l'argent est là il est plutôt pris
dans dans la gestion de la lpm actuelle
parce qu'on sait le faire sans que ça ne
bouscule un programme existant en car je
veux le dire autrement on n'annule pas
on ne retarde pas un programme engagé
pour faire l'art complétude parce qu'à
85 millions d'euros beaucoup de
ministres ne pourrais pas dire ça mais
l'enveloppé globale du ministère des
armées évidemment on peut on peut le
faire et comme façon est à la jonction
des deux helpes et m où il ya bien que
les crédits de paiement mais j'ai
peut-être que gérer dans le détail en ce
qu'on fera l'examen dans l'autre
finances où je rentre peut-être plus
précisément sur ce sujet bon il ya un
enjeu maintenant c'est qu'évidemment la
base industrielle et technologique de
défense suivent c'est évidemment mais
grande conversation avec avec nexter
avec d'autres avec l'ensemble aussi de
la famille des sous traitants donc ça
permet de faire une petite parenthèse
économie de guerre mais je si vous êtes
d'accord je fais une mutualisation de
réponse un pur pour l'ensemble de ce qui
a été dit bon déjà effectivement il ya
un enjeu de simplification normative
après il ya la norme civil et non
militaire
vous êtes intervenu certains d'entre
vous sur le niveau de qualification etc
c'est plutôt l'honneur de l'armée
française et de la dg a que de fournir
aux armes et du matériel fiable
là mais je le dis parce que je sais pas
le cas de tous les pays donc évidemment
de la fiabilité du standard de sécurité
il ne faut pas tomber dans
dans quelque chose qui serait trop
pointilleux sur le terrain administratif
pour des réchauds ça c'est une des
commandes que j'ai passé la délégation
générale à un moment c'est d'assumer le
niveau de risque et airs de classifier
nous règles internes entre ce qui est
secret que ce serait invraisemblable
qu'en france on soit en deçà de ce socle
de contrôle sur nos systèmes d'armement
qu'est-ce qui fait l'objet d'un contrôle
que l'on fait par acquis de conscience
ça veut dire qu'après c'est un risque
qu'on prend à ne pas le faire on est au
moins capables d'identifier x et qu'est
ce que l'on fait parce qu'on est
français qu'on aime bien parfois faire
un peu mieux tout le monde pour être
très clair j'ai demandé à ce qu'on
découpe ça en trois parties étant
entendu quand on est vraiment en guerre
bah on sait très bien que le niveau
d'intensité de contrôle diminue c'est
vieux comme toutes les guerres il suffit
de demander aux usines ford comparaison
n'est pas raison aux états unis lorsque
il s'est agit de développer des chaînes
de production le contrôle qualité sur
des produits qui se fait à des milliers
et des milliers d'exemplaires ne peut
pas être le même contrôle qualité sur
quelques pièces et c'est là on a un
enjeu collectif de cette économie de
guerre c'est comment on ne perd pas en
qualité comme on ne perd pas en sûreté
comment ça coûte pas plus cher parce que
moi j'ai appris dans mes cours
d'économie quand j'étais au lycée et à
la faculté que plus on produit
normalement moins ça coûte cher je sais
qu'une arme c'est plus compliqué que ça
enfin comment on fait tous attention à
l'argent du contribuable
il faut quand même aussi qu'au nom du
fait qu'on doit produire plus et plus
vite il faut pas non plus qu'on explose
les anglais parce qu'on doit aussi aux
contribuables veulent effort important
qui est fait par ailleurs et comme on
arrive à massifier donc ça c'est
évidemment clé les césar avant de venir
peut-être un peu le symbole de sa et
puisqu'on a dû en donner c'est qu'on les
a déjà pas perdu pour les a donnés pour
la bonne cause on n'aurait plus les
faire détruire sur un champ de bataille
et donc c'est un bon cas d'école si on
s'était fait détruire ces 18 canon
caesar sur un champ de bataille
combien de temps nous faut-il
collectivement armes et des jets à
système administratif et budgétaire mais
aussi la base industrielle et
technologique de défense pour la
recomposer c'est le meilleur des cas
pratiques qu'on ne peut avoir pardon de
le dire comme ça on aurait pu s'en
passer c'est moi qu'on puisse aimer mais
ça c'est très très clé après il ya toute
une série pour avoir commencé à
interroger la filière de normes civiles
je suis départements du nord est
maintenant 15 jours ou trois semaines
pour un assemblier de missiles
il m'a dit que son problème c'était sa
capacité à embaucher on est revenu sur
le tout ce que nos territoires nous
suggère dans les capacités à à fidéliser
à former et j'étais revenu sur des
discussions que je peux avoir par
ailleurs dans l'eure avec la mission
locale du coin pôle emploi donc on
n'était pas du tout dans le domaine
militaire ont été sur les enjeux
auxquels notre industrie française de
manière globale est confronté après les
enjeux de temps de travail si on est
vraiment en guerre est ce que le temps
de travail est le même
sans amoindrir notre modèle social donc
ce qu'est ce que les entreprises sont
prêts aussi à faire pour intéresser
leurs salariés et et les intéressés de
manière généreuse parce que je pars du
principe le 6 on est vraiment guerre il
est normal que le parlement abandonné
interroge aussi j'accélère monsieur
président mémé puisse accélérer ses
réflexions
je suis sûr que tu en train de répondre
à plat une question que certains
sénateurs et
je me suis complètement
persuadé sur alors je fais très vite
mais je reviendrai sur les munitions les
600 millions d'euros étaient déjà
engagés avant le sujet c'est d'avoir
quelque chose de nouveau pour l'année
prochaine sur lequel il est un peu tôt
pour moi de vous détailler ça mais au
delà la marche à 3 milliards évidemment
en fonction ce que le m&a et la dgr va
nous dire s'il ya quelques mesures hyper
urgente je me permettrait peut-être de
les présenter en haute finance en plus
de ce qui peut déjà être prévu
c'est pour ça que je fais ce travail un
peu flash sur dame bon vous clairement
les mois qui viennent sont décisifs
parlez-moi les semaines il ya des
derniers essais en fin de cdd et c'est
important qu'ils sont prévues à
l'automne de qualification qui vont
écrire une technologie qui est compliqué
parce que très nouvelles notamment sur
ses poils a enfin vous connaissez bien
tous ces sujets donc en clair ce qui va
être fait à l'automne va être très
déterminant pour la suite du programme
pour faire très vite et pour être pour
être un film enfin les essais se
poursuivent et les crédits sont bien là
des crédits sont là pour les essais en
tout cas si vous passez après le détail
peut-être au sénateur perrin si le s'ils
le souhaitent sur les drones de manière
globale forte des travaux dès que vous
avez pu accomplir et et d'autres travaux
ici ou là il faut qu'on arrive à affirme
un fim et la feuille de route en matière
pas vous dire le contraire on a trop
subi
heureusement que jean yves le drian en
2013 a pris des décisions d'achat
étrangers qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
leur hyper évidemment on l'a vu sur les
champs-elysées a heureusement qu'on les
arbres ça le ministre le drian l'avait
fait en tant que mise de la défense or
mal évidemment faut continuer à faire le
suivi faut bien s'interroger aussi sur
le produit final évidemment parce qu'il
faut que ça corresponde à des besoins en
fonction des théâtres donc on revient
mon introduction sur évidemment là la
qualité des théâtres donnera aussi
drone la technologie qui est recherchée
reconnaissance n'est pas combat
typologie du combat bref là aussi vous
connaissez ces sujets faut aussi citer
quand même le patroller safran quant à
la question que vous m'avez posé sur le
commune sur le la technologie américaine
oui sur le switch pardonnez-moi ont revu
par ben oui on regarde nos aucune
décision n'a été prise actuellement en
tout cas il est vrai que les armes et
regarder se sont documentés sur le sujet
mais aucune décision n'a été prise
pardon monsieur le président mes jeux
merci à l'oeil
je sais pas s'ils présentent leur donne
la parole
skaff pardonnez moi je l'oublié je suis
désolé mais ministre le scaf évidemment
c'est un programme clé c'est normal dans
ce moment oui il mériterait pratiquement
une audition à part entière
néanmoins je ne m'effraie pas des
difficultés de calage du moment parce
que ce sont les derniers gros calage
avant de passer quand même la deuxième
oui mais enfin le premier pilier moi qui
aime bien l'histoire aussi un du cn au
spatial pour avoir été maire de vernon
les gros calage sur ariane comparaison
n'est pas raison et est énorme aussi
j'ai faut c'est que c'est toujours une
aventure c'est gros c'est gros ces
grosses opérations ces grosses
coopération industrielle france on les
soutient tous ou sens où on voit bien
qu'on a intérêt à développer notre
autonomie stratégique européenne et que
évidemment ça pose des questions ça pose
aussi des questions faut respecter les
savoir-faire aussi de chaque maison que
dassault soit vigilant sur ses commandes
de vol par exemple c'est normal que
dassault l'expriment on comprend donc
moi j'ai un agenda notamment avec les
espagnols c'est en partie fait avec les
allemands des rencontres sont prévues à
la fin du mois d'août au début du mois
de septembre sur ce sujet même s'il faut
faire vite merci je t'ai comprimé pardon
alors maintenant donc on a des questions
minutes et avec des réponses qui ce que
vous regrouperait mais qui seront
effectivement ce que bon après je reçois
le haut conseil de la condition
militaire donc
j'ai pas fini ma journée allez françois
bonneau à longvic oui merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre à l'aune
du départ de nos forces du mali et au
regard des influences étrangères que
vous avez déjà évoqué monsieur ministre
et sachant que les l'augmentation des
zones de
d'instabilité dans la région est ce que
vous souhaitez revisiter toute la
présence militaire française en afrique
de l'ouest il semblerait que oui et
pourriez vous nous dire comment dans le
respect bien sûr des souverainetés des
états
andry gueule
merci président et pardonnez moi de
revenir sur des munitions mais il s'agit
plus d'une réflexion que d'une question
notre président christian cambon a
largement relayé le manque de munitions
disponibles permettant à nos armes et
d'assurer convenablement leur mission et
donc notre sécurité il a fait des
responsabilités lucidité ce qui aura
probablement contribué à prendre
sérieusement en considération cet hymne
qui état de situation cependant je suis
toujours très mal à l'aise et en tout
cas très peinés de constater la
médiatisation de cet état de faits peu
glorieux et de voir ainsi notre
vulnérabilité affiché au grand jour dans
un contexte tendu d'augmentation de la
confiture alité aussi ne serait-il pas
envisageable si cela n'a pas été geste
esquissé par la dg a et parlons
militaire de fait de mettre en place
deux types de stock n'est pas de stock
deux types de stocks de munitions au
sein de nos forces armées un premier
stock de munitions stratégique capable
de répondre à la plupart des scénarii
des conflits envisagée ou du moins les
plus probables un stock dit de guerre en
quelque sorte un stock dont le contour
serait largement élaboré par le
parlement avec le parlement mais dont la
confidentialité contribuerez à notre
crédibilité internationale un audit
pourrait être organisé pour chaque type
de munitions dont les contours restent à
définir ça a été dit de manière à
maîtriser toute la chaîne de fabrication
ainsi que les approvisionnements et les
réquisitions reposant exclusivement sont
nos moyens industriels et humains
nationaux car force est de constater que
l'économie libérale mondialisée n'est
pas adapté au domaine de la sécurité
militaire elle nous rend vulnérables et
nous place dans une situation de
dépendance dangereuse je sais qu'il
existe un texte législatif à l'étude
pilotée par la dg en visant à mobiliser
ou a réquisitionné les matériaux des
entreprises civiles à des fins
militaires
au sénat nous l'attendons avec intérêt
ce serait aussi une manière de
réindustrialiser la france est de
traduire l'économie de guerre prônée par
le président la république une économie
de guerre qui sera difficile à mettre en
oeuvre par les pour les équipements et
les pièces de rechange afin d'atteindre
le modèle d'armée complet de demain mais
aussi indispensable et en tout cas à
minima dans le domaine des munitions et
enfin second stocks des munitions
consommables susceptibles de répondre
aux besoins quotidiens de nos forces
armées nécessaires à leur entraînement
ce stock quant à lui plus soumis aux
comptes ou contraintes budgétaires sur
lequel le débat peut facilement
s'instaurer car déconnecté des
contraintes de confidentialité de
défense et ne mettant pas en cause
directement notre vulnérabilité permet
moi d'avoir lu rapidement compte tenu du
temps imparti il est ingénieur
d'armement
alors jean marc d'esquisser le mini
merci monsieur le président je vais
désobéir parce que j'ai assisté à une
audition digne de la préparation du
budget et on avait peut-être pour la
première fois à accueillir le ministre
la fois plus générale moi je vais vous
dire la satisfaction de ce ministre
c'est pas mon habitude un de nous avoir
écoutés je resté jusqu'au bout malgré la
litanie par respect par politesse mais
vous avez chez vous avez intégré tous
très rapidement même s'il ya des notes
je connais le jeu ne vous avez là changé
par rapport aux habitudes qu'on avait
dans les auditions des deux précédents
ministres dans un avec qui j'ai
collaboré
c'est vrai mais je connaissais et c'est
la technique mais vous avez présenté là
en vrai politique et vous avez intégré
je voudrais vous rendre hommage là
dessus alors le précédent quinquennat a
été le président l'a dit le refus de la
réactualisation de la lpm ça a posé des
problèmes ça a amené le premier ministre
de l'époque
un vote négatif ici c'est rare c'est pas
l'habitude de la maison en tout cas de
s'opposer par rapport aux armées et donc
je note avec satisfaction vous vous avez
dit sur le travail avec le parlement
mais madame parler avait dit la même
chose vous avez évoqué le manque de
réactions
politiques et de tous les partis par
rapport à la mise en scène de wagner
mais on avait eu le même cas avec eux
soit disant bombardement du village de
bons outils on avait dû demander à la
ministre écrit au président pour qu'elle
vienne s'expliquer elle avait dit
qu'elle tirerait des conclusions parce
que si vous voulez que l'on intervienne
et compte défendre nos armes et des
choses sauf qu'on fait les choses sont
claires c'est qu'il faut aussi avoir un
minimum de respect vis-à-vis du
parlement et c'est ce que vous donnez
l'impression de vouloir faire je donne
pas le bon dieu sans confession emmène
pas laïque donc
il faut nous associer il faut nous
expliquer et peut-être expliquer qu'à un
représentant par groupe pas s'il ya des
choses qui ne peuvent pas être divulgués
mais on avait fait des propositions
baden par la demande est restée aux
mains de points donc là c'est vrai que
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide
on n'a pas trop bougé
passeur donne l'impression de s'agiter
pour pas grand chose alors vous avez
parlé de la lpm dont il pas revenir
dessus mais le président de république a
dit d'abord réactualisation de la
lpm ensuite il a dit nouvelle lpm tout
simplement quelle va être la
coordination entre ces deux lois de
programmation parce que la loi de
programmation 2019 2025 montée en
puissance maintenant dans les années là
c'est maintenant que les gros enjeux et
des gros efforts financiers devaient
être faits et vous venez de faire et à
juste titre je citerai que le service de
santé des armées c'est quelque chose
d'important et où vous avez commencé à
dire qu'il fallait réinvestir dans
beaucoup de points dont on ne sait pas
trop comment vous allez faire donc elle
et quels moyens et mon courage dans la
discussion des négociations avec votre
collègue du budget
cd période parce que y il va falloir
quand même
effectivement le service de santé des
armées ne peut pas rester comme il est
j'ai connu de l'intérieur c'est très
compliqué donc il nous faudrait un bilan
réel et travailler avec vous sur un
bilan réel de la lpm on courait savoir
comment ça va se passer et puis je ne
vais pas m'étendre faudrait qu'une
question vous avez évoqué le service
national universel
comment quel va être pour le mystère des
armées les objectifs et des moyens qu'il
pourra consacrer parce que si j'écoute
moi je vais te lui installer le service
militaire volontaire à metz ce que
j'avais vu et je veux une déclaration
d'ailleurs ce que vous avez fait sur le
cema je l'avais découvert quand j'étais
chef de cabinet dans une autre vie c'est
quelque chose d'important je vais voulu
qu'on crée le smv et le président
hollande avait voulu on a créé le
premier à metz ça me faisait vraiment
plaisir et j'avais insisté et le s est
nu le s est nulle
pour les rapports hommes les armées va
quand même être
quelque chose d'important à effectifs et
à moyens constants je ne vois pas trop
comment vous allez pouvoir
poursuivre toutes les autres formations
et puis réussira à faire cela donc tout
simplement si vous pouvez nous donner
des explications parce que c'est le
premier but des premiers bilans
peut-être aussi faire un bilan du et
c'est nul parce que si on écoute les
médias ça a été la première phase une
colline vacances la deuxième phase par
une véritable préparation militaire ni
pour les réservistes donc on a là
quelque chose de compliqué sur l'ukraine
j'aurais faire simple on veut parvenir
vous a évoqué mais dans l'opinion
publique aujourd'hui ça donne
l'impression que la france de renault à
renée ne résisterait pas plus quinze
jours c'est sa rade dans la scène
médiatico-politique résisterez pas plus
plein jour si on est confronté à ce qui
se passait là sont ukraine donc là aussi
quelles sont les mesures que vous voulez
prendre pour rassurer je dirais la
population parce que si on veut revenir
et faire confiance à nos armées c'est
pas quelque chose de facile on a bien vu
avec la police souvent la police et la
police et des pompiers au moment des
attentats et puis on a vu ce que ça
donne un an après c'est ils sont mis en
accusation et toi comment s'y prendre
pour redorer je dirais
la confiance des français dans le noir
mais voilà j'ai été long mais bon tu
fais une petite question minutes manière
de monsieur todeschini
olivier cadic aller avançons mais c'est
monsieur le ministre votre propre au
1/10 introductif l'a souligné une part
considérable des équilibres du monde se
joue dans la dos pacifique votre
expérience dans vos précédentes
fonctions de mise d outre-mer vous
permet de disposer déjà d'une fine
connaissance des défis auxquels la
france et l'union européenne sont
confrontés dans laxe indo pacifique en
octobre dernier j'ai fait partie de la
délégation sénatoriale en déplacement à
taïwan conduite par notre collègue alain
richard lorsque nous sommes arrivés 56
avions chinois avait des avait fait une
incursion dans la zone d'identification
de la défense aérienne de l'île taiwan
subi un harcèlement continu de la part
de l'aviation chinoise les incursions
d'avions militaires chinois autour de
taiwan ont progressé de 55% depuis le
début de l'année le 4 juillet des
navires de guerre chinois et russes ont
fait une incursion près des côtes du
japon l'amiral pierre vandier a
récemment évoqué des actes
d'intimidation
devenu régulier en mer de chine le
contre amiral jean mature est commandant
la zone asie pacifique a déclaré nous
avons des frégates de surveillance qui
sont légèrement armés quand on voit la
militarisation du pacifique il faut
revenir à des bateaux mieux armé comme
il ya 30 ans nous avions des bateaux
avec des sonars des torpilles des canons
des missiles parce que malheureusement
c'est une réalité la zone se militarise
et ce bi polarise et la france a besoin
de réagir en conséquence quelle est
votre vision monsieur le ministre pour
mieux affirmer notre présence midi des
militaires dans l'inde au pacifique la
chine entretient de nombreux conflits
territoriaux avec ses voisins japon
vietnam philippines malaisie et bien sûr
taiwan une déclaration chinoise récente
affirme que les eaux du détroit de
taiwan sont sous souveraineté chinoise
le sénat recevra la visite du président
du parlement taïwanais la semaine
prochaine que pourrons-nous lui dire sur
la proche de la france
pour garantir la navigation dans le
détroit de taiwan je vous remercie
merci olivier jacques le nay et merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
la roumanie souhaiterait se procurer un
sous-marin scorpène et des hélicoptères
français confirme confirmez vous ces
intentions le déploiement en roumanie
deux soldats français dans le cadre de
l'otan qu'il participait à une meilleure
entente sur les projets industriels les
questions d'actualité quels moyens
militaires sont actuellement déployés
pour lutter contre les feux qui ravagent
la france
et notamment en gironde mais sont ils
suffisants
merci jacques françois patriat président
je peux danger ou faire gagner du temps
le ministre ayant excellemment répondu
sur les industries d'armement je ne peux
me pose pas la question simplement
peut-être l'effort que fait l'allemagne
aujourd'hui est accolée est conséquent
est ce que nous entendons garder la
parité en matière de défense avec eux et
on parlera de l'effort budgétaire qu'il
faudra faire au moment du pic et voilà
on y est pas encore merci président
guillaume gontard un autre président oui
merci le président monsieur monsieur le
ministre vous avez effectivement répondu
à beaucoup de choses que j'avais du
couvent revenir sur un point que vous
avez évoqué sur le sn ou service
national universel lancé en 2019 et qui
donc a été annoncé qu'ils devaient être
généralisée à toute une classe d'âge en
tout cas c'est ce qui a réaffirmé le le
13 juillet dernier le président de la
république et c'est vrai que pour
l'instant on reste un peu dans le flou
on n'a eu qu'une échéance clair et je
sais pas peut-être que vous allez
pouvoir nous éclairer en tout cas sur
sur ce point en 2021 le et ses nuages
mobilisé 15 mille jeunes volontaires à
peu près 2% des effectifs qu'induire et
sa généralisation or même à une petite
échelle de nombreux problèmes sont
apparus que ça soit sur eux
l'organisation laborieux des incidents
comme celui d'evreux ou encore il ya
quelques semaines a mise en place d'une
scandaleuse punition collective à
strasbourg et cela illustre un problème
majeur qu'on voit apparaître
d'encadrement qui est souvent laissé à
des animateurs sous formés et un manque
de personnel et vous l'avez dit
vous-même nos armées sont déjà employés
sur de multipro front elle ne dispose
pas des capacités matérielles et
humaines pour organiser un scénic qui
concernerait plus de huit cent mille
jeunes donc comment comptez-vous adaptée
en termes d'infrastructures d'accueil
ainsi que d'une personnel y en aura-t-il
suffisamment avec quelle formation etc
et tout cela a un coût et qui n'est pas
négligeable estimé entre 2 et 5
milliards d'euros par an en tout cas on
a besoin tout cas d'avoir des éléments
là dessus à titre de comparaison
l'ouverture du rsa aux moins de 25 ans
coûterait 4 milliards par an une
question de deux choix et 2 et 2 et
d'orientation n'est-il pas donc d'autres
messages envoyés à la jeunesse de france
que cette co tutelle de votre ministère
des armées sur les politiques publiques
qui la concerne cela fait énormément de
moyens financiers et humains pour une
politique publique donc on a du mal
encore avoir le sens merci merci au fifo
lieu
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre
la première des vocations de l'état est
d'assurer la souveraineté cette
souveraineté elle peut être terrestre
mais elle est aussi maritime
vous êtes le premier ministre de la
défense qui était auparavant ministre
des outre mer
les forces de souveraineté ont été les
grandes oubliées pour ne pas dire les
sacrifier des dernières lois de
programmation militaire est ce que dans
ce cadre là vous avez tenu quelques
propos à encourageant mais ce que vous
nous préciser un certain nombre de
points et d'éléments qui font que notre
pays qui se croient continental européen
alors que de fait il est mondial et
maritime pour en assumer les
responsabilités qui sont les siennes et
par rapport à nos collègues qui parlait
tout à l'heure de stratégie indo
pacifique comment valoriser les
possibilités d'appui que nous pouvons
avoir par le biais donc de nos
départements et collectivités
d'outre-mer en la matière et de manière
très concrète vous avez parlé des fremm
des futurs fremm est ce que pour vous
alors qu'à ce jour nous avons à 95% des
moyens en tonnage de la marine nationale
qui sont affectés dans l'hexagone alors
que 97,5 % de notre zone économique
exclusive est liée aux outre-mer est ce
qu'il pourrait y avoir un rééquilibrage
est donc concrètement par exemple à voir
des fremm une fremm qu'ils puissent être
basés dans l'océan indien l'île de la
réunion et une fremm basée dans le
pacifique ce qui serait un élément
important en terme de manoeuvre mais
aussi une affirmation vis-à-vis d'autres
d'autres puissances et je fait notamment
référence à ce qu'est ce qui était dit
tout à l'heure par olivier cadic et qui
serait une signification assez
importante d'une nouvelle volonté
française de vouloir assumer ses
responsabilités en tant que membre de
conseil en tant que membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
merci philippe rachété mal merci prisons
sionistes d'abord merci pour les propos
que j'ai tenus à savoir que le sentiment
à ce stade c'est que le le sénat que le
parlement sera jean veut dire qu'au
constructeur owc aux assembleurs à la
fois de la programmation militaire mais
également de je crois des grands enjeux
militaires dont je crois que c'est une
bonne chose donc l'intention est là et
nous serons à vos côtés bien évidemment
et on espère que ça m'intéresserait moi
j'ai une question sur la question de la
compétition stratégique parce que sur
deux terrains d'opération d'une part sur
l'afrique parce que je crois que quand
même depuis de nombreuses années sur
avec la concurrence de la chine la
russie la turquie on est quand même en
recul et c'est pas les cinq dernières
années que les choses soient claires ça
fait très longtemps et donc la tue
quelle est notre stratégie au delà de
répondre aujourd'hui à la question du
sahel j'entends bien mais globalement on
a quand même je crois besoin d'avoir de
nouveaux nouvelle vision stratégique sur
la question de l'afrique qui est sur les
questions militaires mais bien au delà
en tout cas pour votre zizou sur les
questions militaires la deuxième saut
sur indo pacifique ce que oui la france
n stratégie où ils leur peine
stratégique mais la réalité
c'est beaucoup de stratégies j'en veux
dire d'intention
puisque d'un regard de comme l'évoqué
olivier cadic sur la puissance
américaine la puissance militaire la
monte en puissance et on voit les enjeux
o'leary sur son domaine militaire même
également de d'accès aux matières
premières de de crise etc etc on voit
bien que tout cela est une réalité et
que je pas sûr que certains d'ailleurs
que la seule vision dire nous sommes une
force d'équilibré la troisième voie soit
très durable très longtemps puisque
aujourd'hui nous avons pas forcément la
capacité à être un acteur de premier
plan en tout cas face a effectivement
une chine de plus en plus agressive donc
là aussi quelle est votre vision alors
peut-être que ce sera pas là post et d'y
répondre aujourd'hui mais votre vision
un peu sur indo pacifique au delà des
grandes choses qu'on connaît je crois
qu'il ya vraiment un besoin de revoir en
tout cas nos doctrines sur indo
pacifique et comme nous commettons
actuellement rapport ne seront donc
d'entendre votre vision avant de
répondre d'autres rapports moment venu
merci rachid nicole duranton
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre donc beaucoup de mes questions
ont trouvé réponse ou ont déjà été
posées par mes collègues néanmoins j'en
aurai 2
concernant l'environnement donc votre
ministère contribuer à la politique
d'anticipation sécuritaires
environnementales dans trois domaines
donc l'analyse des risques
environnementaux le soutien des
programmes donc scientifique ciblées et
l'organisation de conférences sur
l'ensemble des zones afin de
sensibiliser nos partenaires aux
conséquences sécuritaires du changement
climatique donc quelles sont les mesures
prises ou envisagées pour enrayer les
conséquences du réchauffement climatique
sur nos armées en matière de protection
des femmes et des hommes et performance
donc des matériels militaires et l'autre
portera donc sur l'otan donc la finlande
bien entendu et la suède ont décidé de
rejoindre l'otan donc la france a dès le
départ soutenu donc le choix souverain
est issue d'un processus démocratique de
nos deux partenaires européens donc à
cette adhésion donc cette décision
permettra de renforcer leur sécurité
face à la menace de leur voisinage mais
aussi de renforcer la place des
européens au sein de l'otan et notre
sécurité collective bien entendu donc
cette sécurité collective passe
nécessairement par une complémentarité
entre l'otan et la défense européenne en
construction à laquelle vous allez donc
largement participé donc ce matin la
commission a adopté le texte permettant
la ratification du protocole d'adhésion
de la finlande et de la suède donc à ce
jour plus de la moitié des états membres
de l'otan ont ratifié le sénat votera
demain donc à quel point de un retard
dans les adhésion à l'otan qu'ils
proviennent du chantage du président
erdogan donc ou des lenteurs dans les
ratifications pourrait créer un risque
militaires supplémentaires pour la
région je vous remercie merci nicole
xori
merci président monsieur le ministre
vous avez terminé vos propos liminaire
en parlant de la résidence résilience de
la nation qui est un sujet qu'on voit
avec un jour un peu nouveau compte tenu
du conflit en ukraine dans son discours
de l'hôtel de brienne le président
macron à fait différentes annonces dont
le doublement des effectifs de la
réserve opérationnelle
pourquoi une telle augmentation et
sommes nous à l'aube d'un changement de
modèle de l'armée française et par
ailleurs il a fait également des
annonces sur la généralisation du s est
nul mais deux de mes collègues vous ont
déjà posé des questions sur ce sujet
mais pour ma part ça tournait autour de
quels moyens quel calendrier ils font
merci
merci hugues joëlle garriaud-maylam
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre pour
votre intervention dont je partage tout
les éléments sauf peut-être en quand
vous dites que l'otan s'est réveillée
soudainement je voudrais quand même dire
que les parlementaires de l'otan ont
beaucoup travaillé sur les sujets que
vous avez évoqué les balkans occidentaux
nous avons fait beaucoup de rapports sur
la résilience par exemple sur la
cybersécurité sur la cyber défense et je
crois aussi que nous avons beaucoup à
apprendre de certains de nos partenaires
de l'otan et aussi des nouveaux entrants
bien sûr l'estonie mais aussi la
finlande et la suède qui ont vraiment
beaucoup développé le concept de
résilience au quotidien de leur pays
pour des raisons évidentes alors moi je
voudrais revenir juste très rapidement
deux points vous avez parlé du lien
nécessaire avec les collectivités
territoriales bravo c'est très important
mais je voudrais vraiment vous demander
de ne pas oublier les français les
tranchées parce que vous avez beaucoup
de français et d'étrangers qui veulent
s'engager vous en avez par exemple
beaucoup aujourd'hui qui veulent
s'engager comme réserviste dans le 27e
bca pourra les aider en roumanie mais
vous avez tout cette réserve citoyenne
qui peut aider justement matière de
cyberdéfense cybersurveillance vous avez
également
les journée défense et citoyenneté qui
ne sont pas organisés partout mais
connaissent savent que c'est un sujet
sur lequel je reviens régulièrement sans
beaucoup de succès mais qui me paraît
extrêmement importants pour construire
cette résilience et ce lien armée nation
enfin j'ai cru apprendre que vous seriez
demain au royaume uni donc je voulais
vraiment vous exhortez sur cette
question de défense franco britannique
qui a été un élément moteur depuis les
accords de lancaster house qui
malheureusement depuis la sphère au cul
c'est un peu tombé
en désuétude et par exemple dont je suis
membre du bureau du conseil franco
britannique nous organisons chaque année
une conférence de défense franco
britannique qui n'a pas été organisé
l'année dernière à cause de la sphère
rochus le votre prédécesseur souhaitait
attendre un peu du fait des problèmes
avec boris johnson avant d'en organiser
une nouvelle mais je crois vraiment que
ce serait un magnifique signal de
relance et le plus vite possible cette
conférence franco britannique de défense
qui a toujours été extrêmement
importante et influente merci beaucoup
monsieur mines
merci joël et nous terminons par la
bretagne philippe paul le marin de
service merci oui ce sera une question
arménienne monsieur polident
bien monsieur le ministre tout à leur
président comme on a évoqué un sujet qui
m'intéresse beaucoup c'est l'armée de
l'air avec la disponibilité des rafales
j'avoue que je suis extrêmement inquiet
je pensais que vous aurez répondu avait
pas fait donc je pars non non non la
géographe à l'armée de l'air d'envoyer
ils sont un peu taquin enfin faudra
s'habituer oui je suis un peu inquiet au
niveau de la capacité opérationnelle de
l'armée de l'air où comme vous savez
nous avons rendu un certain nombre
d'appareils de qui viennent de deux
escadrilles donc on a quand une perte
capacité d'environ 10% déjà que le
niveau était pas au niveau du nombre son
vote il bien bien inférieur à ce qu'il
faudrait qu'elle soit est hélas ici dans
cette salle me madam parle il nous a dit
qu'elle n'était pas inquiète au niveau
de la capacité opérationnelle de l'armée
de l'air que tout serait fait pour que
ses ventes seraient remplacés par des
appareils neufs au plus vite ce qui
n'est pas du tout l'avis du général
boucard et encore moins du général 1000
à côté ça je viens de regarder les
chiffres de mc au la disponibilité
opérationnelle des rafale à l'armée de
l'air s'élève pas plus de 56% ce qui
veut dire si je calcule rapidement et un
peu en arrondissant on a une soixantaine
d'appareils qui sont vraiment en état de
voler à l'heure actuelle ce qui est
extrêmement faible donc je veux savoir
quelle était votre avis sur ce sujet
voilà monsieur le ministre
oui une vraie séance de questions
cribles
bon dans certains sujets mais est un
indic mans dépendent audition aussi
avant qu'après ça permet de retoucher de
revenir sur la méthode comment vous
souhaitez travailler mais ce président
est monsieur commissaire aussi se
prendre des sujets et faire la
profondeur voilà parce que là sinon
c'est alors monsieur le sénateur bonne
mais je sais pour ça je suis venu ce n
est pas député
j'assume j'assume le bicamérisme
j'assume j'assume le bicamérisme très
bien j'en suis un grand défenseur et
j'assume cette coquetterie
oui mais site de l'autre côté de la
seine on se rappelle qu'elle sénat c'est
une bonne nouvelle
monsieur le sénateur bono sur la
présence militaire française en afrique
de fait
il ya un tournant il n'est pas propre à
ce qui se passe au sol mali il n'est pas
propre d'ailleurs au sol français je
pense que tout ce que j'ai dit en
proposant du ctif sur les nouveaux
risques de sécurité avec ses terrasses
on tabasse oncle et si je devais dire
les choses en deux phrases ces pigments
voilà un sujet qui pourrait prendre
plusieurs heures donc faut le dire un il
faut que les états amis de la zone
formalisent leur expression de besoin
ils disent ce qu'ils attendent de nous
ne peut pas y avoir de malentendu et
c'est comme ça qu'on respecte aussi la
souveraineté et c'est comme ça aussi que
l'on en arrive à avoir un des
partenaires de très grande qualité c'est
le message qui a été portée devant le
président bazoum c'est le message qui a
été portée devant le président ouattara
en fin de semaine dernière le deuxième
des choses
la présence française ne peut pas être
que militaire et là nous au sein de
l'état
en cela on à devoir de coordination plus
fort avec l'afd avec les politiques
culturelles sportives énergétique
d'accès à l'eau potable on ne peut pas
résumer la présence française dans un
pays d'afrique à sa seule présence
militaire sans quoi nous nous enfermons
ou même dans un spectre et de partout p3
donc ça c'est un agenda qui est lourd
parce que sa demande de coordonner plus
fortement plus en profondeur mais moi
j'y crois énormément
parlé entre états c'est une chose
parlait entre parlement c'est
indispensable mais dont il faut parler à
la population et d'ailleurs si vous avez
d'accord je l'emmènerais un certain
nombre de parlementaires régulièrement
sur mes déplacements en afrique parce
que je pense que par définition les
démocraties représentatives passe par
des parlements et donc il faut aussi que
les parlements africains puissent
discuter avec leurs homologues français
pour aussi que n'y a pas que le ministre
il faut aussi que les les parlementaires
français puis faire la pédagogie de ce
que vous avez décidé ce que vous avez
voté etc et ça c'est important parce que
quand on perd quand on finit par perdre
les coeurs fini par perdre les foules et
c'est bien l'enjeu est évidemment de ce
que nous devons faire dans les derniers
mois qui viendront évidemment en afrique
mais je pourrais revenir de manière plus
en plus précises sur les munitions je
reviens pas chose qui a été dit mais
vous me permettez donné au moment de
préciser quelque chose il ya quand même
beaucoup de contre vérités qui circulent
dans la presse il n'a jamais été écrit
dans le rapport de madame miralas
typiquement que nous avions trois jours
de stock de munitions jamais je suis ce
serait faire le café donc je pense aussi
qu'il faut dire que ont fait un retour
d'expérience et qu'on doit être au top
et qu'on n'est peut-être pas
complètement au top c'est pas pareil que
de dire qu'on a des problèmes de stocks
et c'est ce que je vous disais à propos
introductif et surtout devant des
commissaires connaisseur des questions
de défense et on mélange tout on mélange
de munitions individuel les roquettes
les moyens sol sol sol rrrr mais parfois
il faut challenge est aussi quand on
entend des choses parce que ça soit ça
voudrait dire au fond que nos grands
chefs militaires seraient tous des
incompétents les uns capable il faut
quand même aussi au monde et faire
attention à ce qu'on laisse dire parce
que donc collectivement après on met
trop d'argent pas assez d'argent pour va
faire plutôt faire ceci ça c'est le
coeur de nos discussions stratégiques
mais laissé entendre qu'on aurait laissé
des stocks complètement fondre c'est pas
vrai il faut quand même aussi le dire
d'enclencher sur certains types de
munitions pour certains types de combats
dans certains types de séquences
opérationnels sur lequels oui il est
clair que ce qui se passe en ukraine
était plus complètement d'actualité
c'est trente ou quarante dernières
années et que donc d'autres moyens se
sont développées d'ailleurs plutôt des
moyens balistique plus lourd donc en
fait on va revenir aussi plutôt sur des
stratégies de petites munitions si on
devait le dire aussi de manière un peu
grand public donc ça évidemment il faut
qu'on en fasse ce ce catéchisme
républicain ce qui me permet de parler
au ministre de des skinny dont je
remercie son propos parce que je connais
son caractère bon chat échaudé craint
l'eau froide
chat échaudé craint l'eau froide e vous
avez raison donc je le dis d'autant plus
de sincérité que le meilleur moyen c'est
de fait de dire les choses et que au
moment où le parlement peut se sentir
mis de côté ou négligés il faudra tout
simplement le dire et je m'efforcerai
d'être là ce qu'il faut juste c'est que
comme je le disais qu'on défende aussi
notre souveraineté puisqu'on peut pas
parler de souveraineté toutes les 3
minutes et que la séance de contrôle se
transformant en vulnérabilités pour
l'extérieur donc après c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure il faut trouver
les moments où on peut se protéger
numériquement si j'ose dire pour un
échange de contrôle à l'ancienne entre
le parlement et les ministres et pense
évidemment que je serai je serai votre
ombre sur eux 2023 ces clés depuis l'âge
entre les deux doigts programmation
militaire la marche à 3 milliards
d'euros elle est déjà remplie quand on
lance des grands projets capacitaire
quand on a des programmes de recherche
la diffusion nucléaire de troisième
génération tous ces sujets bas
évidemment ça consomme déjà du crédit de
paiement avant même que la loi soit
votée donc ça veut dire que si elle
n'était pas votée la loi de finances on
parle beaucoup d'elle pm m'enfin faut
aussi qu'on re explique à nos
concitoyens que ce sont les lois de
finances de chaque année tu ouvres les
crédits de paiement les autorisations
d'engagement pas eu de programmation
militaire jeudi parce que la situation
politique de l'assemblée nationale pour
répondre bureau 6 1 une navette
parlementaire plus compliqué en loi de
finances avec des groupes politiques à
l'assemblée qui pourrait ne pas s'en
sortir liés par la loi de programmation
militaire qui a été voté non mais j'en
pense j'ai entendu aussi certains
groupes à l'assemblée nationale non mais
il ya un fait politique nouveau donc
faut aussi qu'on a qu'on intègre mais en
tout cas on pourra y revenir il ya un
élément nouveau qui est quand même en
train d'apparaître c'est l'inflation la
chose qui n'existait pas au moment où
nous avons voté la lpm complet d'une
glissade
quand même inquiétant l'inflation ou
même les mesures sociales que de bonnes
mesures sociales que nous prenons points
à 10 autant de sujets évidemment qu'ils
sont qui sont pas neutres sur lequel je
pourrai revenir dans les instances de
contrôle pour la loi de finance
évidemment sur le et ses nus bon ça
c'est un sujet
majeur je pense que on est en train de
faire ce que je pense plus je suis
certain que nous sommes en train
d'affiner le cahier des charges de la
suite boisclair pour faire des
propositions et sarah elle rit
évidemment la nouvelle
catane est en phase iv être renouvelé
dans ses fonctions avec deux mises de
tutelle était la disposition du
parlement pour répondre à ac à vos
questions le fond de ma pensée rudy
aussi un élu local et ses nuits ou pas
et c'est nu toute façon la relation
entre les armées la jeunesse mais mérite
de toute façon d'être traités déjà parce
que la jia devenu la journée
citoyenne et c'est bon ça mérite quand
même d'être interrogé à mon avis évalué
en disant ça comme ça je pense que le
statu quo n'est pas une option je pense
qu'il faut faire quelque chose de
nouveau vous l'avez dit monsieur le
ministre le service militaire adapté
quelque chose méconnue dans l'hexagone
et vous aviez lance effectivement le smv
élevé c'est ma foi quand j'entends
quelques critiques en disant
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ça des
militaires vont s'occuper de jeunes il
suffit de connaître les outre-mer pour
savoir que c'est un modèle formidable
d'ailleurs que d'aucuns reproché à
michel debré d'en faire une institution
coloniale dans les discussions
parlementaires des années 50 et 60
aujourd'hui c'est probablement
l'institution la plus républicaine et
qui réconcilie tout le monde vous avez
de jeunes kanaks indépendantistes
peut-être de culture politique qui sont
fiers de servir dans les compagnies de
bourail
ou de koné en nouvelle calédonie nom le
laissait mal invite à la a évité de son
de caricatures sur la relation entre la
jeunesse et et l'armée parce que je n'ai
pas entendu ici mais davantage entendu
dans les médias où l assemblée nationale
donc je le dis qu'il faut avoir un
agenda sur ce sujet est entendu que le
président à un public à tracer une ligne
claire c'est que
cela ne sera pas pris sur les moyens
dédiés aux armes et les moyens dédiés
aux armées sont faits pour avoir des
effets militaires réelles c'était
surtout ça notre sujet exact
l'occupation depuis le début est en
revanche on a désormais un nouvel
entrant c'était le point votre penderie
le sénateur s'est en revanche on ne peut
plus faire l'économie de la question de
la résilience globale avec des réponses
diverses mais quelque part ce que je dis
sur le service de santé des armées tout
à l'heure et les réseaux revenu c'est ça
son déjà un des modules de réponse de la
résidence globale donc ça c'est un sujet
global par définition en tant que tel
dans le smt être une brique mais sur
lequel il est clair que nous devons
affiner la feuille de route pas de doute
sur le sujet et pas deux et pas de
langue de bois
vous avez raison subissent de rappeler
pareil dans le champ médiatico politique
d'où sort l'idée que nous tiendrons
quinze jours en cas d'invasion je suis
étonné aussi qu'une question de papus
7,7 contre vérités déjà parce que aussi
nous sommes d'une puissance dotée on
finit par oublier le rôle est le sens
profond la dissuasion nucléaire dont je
rappelle je renvoie vers le discours que
chaque chef d'état prononce à chaque
septennat au quinquennat depuis que avec
française est doté depuis le président
du général de gaulle qui a une doctrine
d'emploi qui fait que si nos intérêts
vitaux profonds sont évidemment menacé
il est clair que c'est un des éléments
de réponse bon pas le seul est pas le
premier c'est le défensif est suffisant
bon c'est ce qu'a dit le président la
république mais il est clair qu'on est
une armée et qu'on a une armée est
capable de se battre et que d'ailleurs
parlons mais faut le redire aux
françaises et aux français on est une
arme et qui en plus se bat déjà sur des
théâtres très différents donc laisser à
penser qu on serait tous d'érable à ce
point
est une contre vérité totale
total est ce qu ont tous points on est
tous bons non c'est le sens de l'effort
budgétaire historique que nous refaisons
collectivement avec voter c'est ça on a
un modèle d'armée qui est complet mais
parce qu'il est complet il faut veiller
à leur complété en permanence en
fonction de l'épaisseur de cette
complétude c'est ça l'enjeu de des
discussions stratégiques et que
l'innovation passe par là l'hybridité
passe par là le sider passe par les
drones passe par là donc on en a terminé
de mise à jour il faut en plus avaler un
nouveau chantier d'innovation c'est ça
le blog global c'est autant la
disponibilité des avions de chasse cher
aux marins de douarnenez et de l'autre
côté
notre capacité bon sur l'hybridité c'est
simple à l'agenda que le nôtre danse
masculine donc ça évidemment c'est un
point particulièrement
clé sur lequel on aura l'occasion d'y
revenir j'insiste sur le sujet numérique
sur les sujets cyber
sait on est loin du capacitaire
classique mais
c'est un des gros morceau de notre foi
de programmation militaire à venir
monsieur le sénateur kelly car l'un
d'eux pacifique bon taiwan déjà on le
redit au delà des éléments de langage
diplomatique pas le dialogue de se
poursuivre entre taiwan et la chine pas
de doute là-dessus et la diplomatie
français sion poids c'est la partie de
madame colonna je pense qu'elle a dû
vous en parlait hier nous pour la partie
militaire il est clair que nous nous
devons de de garantir le droit
international maritime sur la liberté de
circulation et la navigation
et à cela ça me permettra de compléter
tout à l'heure mais il est clair que les
missions que nous avons pu commencer à
faire des patrouilles dans les eaux
internationales
participent à cela l avantage je pense à
faire la double réponse après sa sortie
mal mais le le le fait de ne d'être un
liés mais non-alignés et puissant
équilibre fait aussi que temps quand un
sous marin nucléaire d'attaqué français
comme nous l'avons fait se balade entre
guillemets dans la zone les différents
acteurs de ladite zone regarde aussi ce
sous marin nucléaire pour ce qu'il est
une patrouille visant à faire respecter
le droit international maritime ces
précieux parce que c'est là où la
posture diplomatique vient rejoindre
évidemment la manoeuvre opérationnel
militaire et ça mais je reviendrai sur
l'agenda de l'inde au pacifique il faut
qu'on continue donc ça veut dire aussi
commencent à faire la jonction avec la
question d'un sénateur folio ça veut
donc dire que soit en projection depuis
l'hexagone soit en résidence depuis nos
territoires de souveraineté parce que
c'est la france et que ce sont des
territoires d'outre-mer français et
quand cela d'ailleurs l'agenda
calédonien a permis de répondre à un
certain nombre de questions il faudra
évidemment continuer d'avoir cette
réflexion d'un avec des moyens très
clair mais je compléterai dans un
instant monsieur le sénateur l'aîné nous
avons signé une lettre d'intention pour
l'achat de sous-marins de classe
scorpène avec la roumanie je les signe
et moi même lors de ma visite en marge
de la visite du président de la
république la visite aux forces dans le
cadre de nos actions de nation cadre bon
une lettre d'intention c'est le début de
la première marche maintenant il faut il
faut continuer à discuter mais de fait
l'activité maritime en mer dans en mer
noire et
reprend aussi un agenda nouveau avec ce
qui se passe en ukraine cela va sans
dire donc des discussions ce se
poursuivre sur incendie il ya beaucoup
de moyens militaires engagés différentes
natures des moyens humains déjà parce
que nos bases aériennes disposent de
sapeurs pompiers de l'air qu'on a pu
évidemment mettre en confort pour les 10
les armées ont un rôle clé dans
l'accueil et l'hébergement de tous les
renforts qui viennent de toutes parts
pour se rendre en gironde pato de faire
venir des gens encore faut-il les faire
dormir les nourrir donc ce sont des
armées qui se sont en grande partie
assuré de ce soutien il ya des matériels
particulier que les armes et on confié
ou enfin continuent d'utiliser mes sous
le contrôle de l'autorité préfectorale
du ministère de l'intérieur typiquement
caracal qui a été apprécié ce que j'en
ai compris nous avons également fait
décoller des moyens de de renseignements
ou de surveillance pour permettre
d'anticiper justement des départs de feu
ou des ddt propagation de feu sur
certaines zones des moyens type de
bulles également ont été confiées et
parce qu'un certain nombre de questions
se sont posées sur les réseaux sociaux
je confirme qu évidemment sur une base
aérienne de cazaux nous avons mis
l'ensemble de notre notre flotte de
chasse de notre aviation de chasse
pardonnez-moi à l'abri et en protection
ça va sentir beaucoup des armées sont
engagés les présence d'un public en ce
moment même d'ailleurs sur le terrain
avec le miser l'intérieur et doit être
ramené à repréciser tout ça sur monsieur
le ministre patriat l'effort budgétaire
allemand il est annoncé c'est donc une
bonne nouvelle maintenant nous allons
voir comment il va être exécuté
puisqu'une fois plus c'est ça qui est
clé cd former des ter rain l'occasion de
reparler avec nos partenaires bon les
milliards sont une chose les programmes
d'armement où la cartographie
d'implantation des bases ou des
régiments sont une autre où la doctrine
d'emploi de ses forces armées en sont
encore autre chose monsieur le président
de bontin
je vous ai répondu indirectement oui on
nous devons clarifier le calendrier le
cahier des charges ce que l'on trouvera
dans ce service national universel pour
la suite
il y avait une dimension un peu
embryonnaire aujourd'hui nous l'assumons
complètement sur la base du volontariat
volontariat pour les jeunes même s'ils
vivent ailleurs pour l'encadrement tous
celles et ceux qui ont visité les cordes
sur le terrain ont quand même pu voir de
la joie de l'engagement la volonté de 10
trouvait aussi du sens et un
apprentissage de la république tout ça
je prends c'est consensuel le sujet
c'est la suite et la suite pose des
questions et budgétaires et
organisationnelles qui sont des
questions des questions qui sont
importantes et notamment aussi en lien
avec les collectivités territoriales
donc là aussi je le dis tout à l'heure
c'est important que vous avez parlé de
message à la jeunesse et passages qui
permet de répondre quand même que les
armées ont toujours donné de beaux
messages à la jeunesse pour quiconque
regarde dans les armées pour évidemment
ce qu'elle est monsieur le sénateur
folio j'accélère pour les réponses mais
j'essaie d'être compris souveraineté
maritime alors oubliez vous êtes un peu
dur mais comme je vous connais depuis
longtemps c'est parce que vous parlez
coeur des sujets typiquement
heureusement que la lpm actuelle permet
d'avoir une nouvelle génération de
patrouilles hors outre mer parce que
sinon franchement là ça serait vraiment
terrible si on ne les avions pas je
pense que la technologie des drones
aussi peut être appelé pour la
surveillance de la zone économique
exclusive
ça c'est clé tout les et 2 ne se valent
pas dans la facilité avec lesquels on
les contrôle une île cher à votre coeur
à savoir clipperton évidemment est la
plus difficile pour surveiller leur
intégrité et la surveillance de ces de
ces eaux là où évidemment d'autres
territoires comme la réunion nombre de
forces armées positionner les choses
sont plus évidents je note quand même
que entre 2017 et 2022 les armes et au
fait un boulot de films remarquables
regardez le nombre de cas de blue beauté
autres qu'ils pouvaient rentrer dans les
eaux territoriales et les zones
économiques exclusives
calédoniennes en 2017 en 2018
aujourd'hui on ne connaît plus ce genre
de phénomène parce que les techniques
dans développé par les armes et
fonctionne malheureusement dans d'autres
zones avec une amie qui suivent d'autres
pays que ces inclusions se font mais
c'est un sujet environnemental majeur
notamment aussi pour eux pour la pêche
monsieur le sénateur était mal alors sur
l'ado pacifique
c'est plus qu'une stratégie d'intention
quand même je parlais des missions
militaires elles sont quand même unique
elles vont continuer donc le président
américain demande à l'état-major des
armées de planifier pour 23 24 des
missions de ce type ça faisait quand
même longtemps qu'on avait pas des
chasseurs dans le ciel polynésien ça dit
quelque chose on peut sur dans
l'ensemble de la zone pareil sur le
sénat on a quand même des relations avec
des pays de l'axé du pacifique qui
s'affermit
indonésie inde singapour commence plus
nos forces prépositionnées émirats
arabes unis djibouti plus nos
territoires d'outre-mer on est loin de
quelque chose de théorique la question
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on en fait et qu'elle
est l'art d'exécution de la stratégie
mais les moyens ils sont mais il est
clair ça me permet de faire une réponse
encore mutualisés il faudra de là où je
viens un titre outremer slash indo
pacifique parce que c'est parce que nous
sommes vivre on a une crédibilité aussi
dans cet univers-là à avoir justement
des moyens qui sont dédits faudra aussi
des stratégies dédié voit pas le temps
de reparler du rôle de l'otan dans les
années qui viennent enfin moi je fais
partie de ceux qui considèrent que si on
veut de crédit dans le dos pacifique il
faut davantage pour partir de structures
comme la zean pour avoir un agenda
asiatique un agenda de pacifique plutôt
que de s'appuyer sur une alliance qui
est atlantique est authentique c'est
qu'on n'est pas pacifique donc ça aussi
faudra y travailler et la fermait parce
que lorsque nous sommes en discussion
dans les cadres otaniens ces sujets ne
sont pas toujours si consensuel que cela
entre les différents alliés et les
représentants différents représentants
des jarrets l'instant l'entendent
également de le re de leur côté pour
ajouter les stratégies sur les câbles
également la question était posée et ces
cris évidemment climat vous n'êtes
audible avec les pays insulaire
d'océanie
dès lors que vous traiter la question du
réchauffement climatique parce que il
n'ya pas une conversation avec un
ministre de fidji de papouasie nouvelle
guinée de vanuatu qui ne démarre par la
question de l'événement du niveau de la
mer ge et c'est parce qu'on est une
diplomatie climatique assez forte que
mine de rien on a réussi à créer une
forme de crédibilité parce que
précisément nous mêmes nous avosn ozil
de territoires ultramarins donc tout ça
est un ensemble là aussi sur lequel il
faut être assez compris même la
sénatrice duranton il est clair que
certaines recherches en poche une autre
je parlais de réchauffement climatique
les marins évidemment la marine
nationale a pris une longueur d'avancé
station de météo de la marine à face au
nombre de programmes de recherche
évidemment sont à clarifier a poussé
parce que nous le voyons plus de quelles
sont les conséquences du réchauffement
climatique ont malheureusement des
conséquences de sécurité et donc devront
trouver des réponses militaires je
n'espère pas mais peut-être dans les
décennies qui viendront donc nous devons
également d'être en pointe a su suède
finlande merci pour le travail
formidable que le sénat en peu de temps
un conflit on l'avait compris
collectivement en soit envoyé un message
politico diplomatique en étant un des
premiers pays à ratifier
évidemment l'adhésion on envoie un
signal qui est du concret bon donc nous
mêmes comme membre important de l'otan
on en voit se signala et c'est
évidemment clé il faut veiller à st à ce
stade on voit pas de pays qui
serait entravée dans leur procédure
parlementaire pour des raisons exogènes
parce que les discussions je crois
qu'ils vont nous regarder que les trois
pays en question le secrétaire général
de l'otan
avec turquie souhaite finlande sg autant
ne laisse pas à penser qu'ils aient des
entraves exogènes en revanche les vie
politique intérieure à chaque pays à
chaque parlement ça je ne sais pas
besoin de cette question me faudra
évidemment le vérifier en tout cas nous
notre honneur à nous français c'est que
la parole du sommet se traduise vite par
des parlements qui s'exprime ce qui me
permet de dire à même la sénatrice que
le temps a suffisamment été caricaturé
pendant la campagne présidentielle en
disant tout et n'importe quoi
pour que l'assemblée parlementaire de
l'otan ont repris aussi une place
particulière parce que l'otan ce n'est
pas qu'une réunion avec des chefs d'état
spa qu'une réunion avec des ministres
les peuples y sont aussi représentés et
ça plus personne ne le dit mais donc il
faut aussi qu'on arrive de nouveau avoir
un agenda parlementaire sur ce sujet sur
les réserves c'est un sujet à part
entière on a besoin des réserves tout
simplement parce que plein de métiers ne
sont plus permanent et que
je je le disais pour le sssa pour
certaines compétences plutôt que de
sous-traiter parfois vaut mieux convoqué
un réserviste quelques jours l'année moi
même je lui fais comme gendarme et donc
les réserves c'est un lien précieux on
parle ni armés nationaux ce cas pas plus
concret pour le coup que la réserve
c'est bon pour les finances publiques
c'est bon pour la citoyenneté c'est bon
pour l'implantation territoriale des
forces armées parce que ça crée un tissu
très résilient et ses bons cas de coup
dur et pas que pour faire la guerre pour
d'autres sujets et pareil je redis ce
sont souvent les réserves et le sm a
d'ailleurs je le redis en outre mer qui
va ce qui est une catastrophe climatique
sont en première ligne y compris pendant
le coït donc ça aussi je serai à votre
disposition pour traiter ce sujet de
manière plus précise france et
d'étranger pareil je pense que ça vaut
le coup d'avoir une réflexion plus plus
plus plus fine je suis pas expert mais
vous ne me prendrez
demain au royaume uni j'y crois beaucoup
[Musique]
je pense que le break site ne change pas
beaucoup
je sais que ce que je dis là est un peu
nouveau mais dans la bouche d'un
ministre français mais le bric si tu ne
changes pas le constat de ces de notre
âge notre sécurité collective en europe
devient une armée assez intéropérables
qui ont eu l'habitude de faire beaucoup
de choses ensemble ce sont deux pays
dotés de pays de l'otan enfin à qui on
doit beaucoup
mrs quinine dira pas le contraire à qui
on doit beaucoup sur le terrain de la
mémoire et pour cause parce que les
britanniques ont été là l'un des moments
plus que difficile donc oui demain je
passerai une journée entière et ben
wallace avec un agenda franco
britannique sur veut enfin tout cas les
perspectives un agenda nouveau
franco-britannique pour permettre
d'avoir un certain nombre d'actions
concrètes et pâques industriels je pense
aussi que
il faut tous azimuts le faire et c'est
d'ailleurs les parlements peuvent aussi
le faire ensemble ça serait évidemment
une bonne chose sur la capacité
des
de l'avion de l'aviation de chasse
française bon moi je ne trouve pas le
prélèvement des stocks à l'exportation
et la disponibilité opérationnelle parce
que vous l'avez pas fait mais je le dis
pour eux c'est eux qui nous écoutent
parce que bon on a suffisamment dit
qu'on n'arrivait pas à exporter nos
rafale pendant dix ans maintenant que
tout le monde ne l'achetez en 5 a fait
un bien bizarre est bien curieux
peut-être bien français que de le
déplorer donc c'est normal et le tout
c'est de les remplacer le tout c'est de
tenir les délais pour le faire et c'est
vrai qu'il faut reconnaître à dassault
sa résilience sa capacité assez
remarquable à le faire sur le volet
budgétaire les moyens sont là on aura
l'occasion d'en reparler dans votre
finances et s'il ya bien une entreprise
qui me semble bien comprendre ce que
j'essaie de faire avec sous l'autorité
du président à un public sur l'économie
de guerre c'est bien dassault aviation
qui peut être dans les temps qui
viendront seront amenés à repréciser
leur capacité à monter en charge sur la
manière de produire ça aussi c'est un
sujet qui est très long dont je pourrais
être plus haut parleurs présence
heureusement d'azun non non non non vous
connaissez bien vos dossiers comment ça
merci infiniment pour cette ce premier
contact qui nous a permis de mesurer
tout le travail d'imprégnation de cette
formidable matière que vous avez purée
réalisé dans un temps quand même assez
record donc je pense qu'on aura
l'occasion notamment à la faveur d'une
discussion budgétaire et puis de la mise
en route de cette prolongation
renouvellement
rénovation de la lpm nous aurons
l'occasion j'espère de deux de
poursuivre ce dialogue en tous les cas
je encore une fois je retiens votre
volontiers d'être votre volonté de
travailler avec le parlement je pense
que c'est la meilleure direction que
vous puissiez suivre car ici au sénat ne
sommes pas dans une opposition stupides
nous sommes dans une opposition
constructive et donc à chaque fois que
les choses marchent bien dans les
appeaux on les aide je crois que la lpm
en a été un très bel exemple ou
proportionnellement notre score avait
été nettement supérieures à l'assemblée
nationale si je me souviens bien merci
infiniment monsieur le ministre est donc
à nous revoir bientôt sur tous ces
sujets mais vous avez vu que vous pouvez
vous appuyer sur une commission qui
connaît bien cette
thématique et qui est tout à fait prête
à vous aider si on prend en
considération le rôle que le parlement
peut jouer dans ces affaires de défense
merci à vous tous demain matin 11h le
traité fin finlande suède